hey what's going on it's Bill Burr and
it's time for the Thursday afternoon
just before Friday Monday Morning
podcast and if you're watching this you
know that I'm I'm not a vain person okay
I'm not the kind of person that films
myself just to film myself you know like
some other [__] politicians out there
um you know that that if I film myself
that means I have a guest and you know I
don't bring a guest on unless I respect
them sort of
no unless I respect them it's one of my
old friends in comedy he's got a new
stand-up special called what a day
coming out December 13th on Netflix the
one the only the breadwinner and the
bread maker Mr Tom Papa
Billy thanks for having me no worries so
you gotta look at you yeah look at you
you went out and you filmed a goddamn
special yeah I did another one where'd
you do this one at in Boston you did at
the Wilbur at the Wilbur yeah she shows
at the Wilbur how was it it was great
well it's great to have you back Tom
it was good it was really uh I had the
Wilbur on my calendar I was like why
don't we just shoot it there like that's
right that's what's better place and
then um it all worked out we just put
another show when did you shoot it uh
October 1st
of this year yeah you push it out that
fast yeah
shot it they liked it edited it they
said can we get it on before the end of
the year we said yeah we can do it well
I mean it's not that much to do it isn't
you know usually like one show more than
the other yeah and everybody else likes
the other one and then the other one's
like a parts car you know you need to
take a little Muffler here a little side
here and you got yourself a nice show
yeah but what are you gonna do about an
act though an act yeah you mean like
when I go back on tour yeah
um just fake it fake it right hey look
at your shirt that's pretty good hey
what do you think you've been married
the Plate's spinning
I've got uh I've got like probably 20
that I'm happy with right now there you
go that means you have a good 30. you
have a height you have high standards
yeah so uh it'll it'll come in I don't
have to really go hard on the road until
like end of January oh is that right
yeah oh that's great I'm actually in
good shape wrapping up my my uh my tour
yeah uh next two weekends and uh then I
don't have anything I don't know nothing
nothing I'm not doing anything uh three
glorious months uh it's gonna be back to
the Grind but I'm just gonna take like a
little summer vacation in the winter
yeah that's good yeah you need to you
need to it's uh
and then you I don't know I go back and
forth like I burn out I don't want to
like right now I'm pretty burnt you know
I've been going hard for a couple years
and I'm pretty spent Cynthia my wife
sent me a message the other day and said
did you move out on me and not tell me
oh wow because I just haven't been home
and uh so I'm a little burnt out but
then like I'm home for like two three
weeks and then you start getting like
itchy not to travel but just to do spots
I know I start to feel weird I feel
after three weeks it goes one way or the
other uh-huh I don't think I'm ever
gonna do this again
I'm happier than I've ever been I like
to sit around doing nothing putsing
around the [__] house it is nice when
you're when you're home for a bit and
then you're like oh I haven't gone
through this stack of mail like I
haven't even had the time to like write
all that little [__] like that you you
know there's there's an upside to a
pandemic yeah I know if there just
wasn't the fear of what's gonna happen
yeah to just I mean I think everybody
this whole [__] thing where they're
like you know can I already buddy you
know people don't want to work it's like
no no no no no no they [__] had time
to contemplate and they saw the way you
were treating them if you were treating
them right right and you were paying
them right they'd come down and take
your [__] job you [__] they always
the abusers always blame the people
they're abusing oh there's a reason why
people are not coming back and they're
not coming back to like the hardest jobs
like the housekeepers the Food Service
people like those people like yeah that
grind get that grind just that horrible
grind why won't they just pay him I know
that's my whole thing about all this
whole [__] corporate mentality is
like how much [__] money do you need
to make
this is the thing like we know as far as
like polluting the ocean and all of that
[__] yeah that's never going to get
fixed it's like there's no money there's
no money in recycling there's no money
and it's like there's no money in
thinking about kids future the planet
will leave I can't make any money on
that well I care I'm gonna be dead the
only way to get it because these
corporations you know yeah you're not
gonna be able to rebel against them at
this point yeah especially with the cops
up in San Francisco with that murder
robot they just bought how did San
Francisco go from we're not going to
even tell people like you should get off
the street and go live inside too we're
going to shoot you with robots yeah I
don't know how is that's a ball
it's a don't jump
I don't know yeah that's on the ground
you must comply I don't I'm sitting
there going like what are they what are
they going to be taken away from us that
they're preparing for that they need to
do all of this I mean is it really is it
because there's so many lunatics that go
out and buy an AR-15 so then the cops
are like they're just playing like this
it's almost like the cold war between
[__] lunatics yeah but it doesn't
make sense and cops but in San Francisco
like they went from we're not going to
even police downtown just come into
Louis Vuitton and just take everything
you want or they gave like homeless
people a stipend right that was the best
thing they give them a stipend every
month to get them off the street and
then they would they would rent a hotel
room for a week and just do [__]
drugs and then the next week they'd be
broke again ah just walking around I
need some more money pal yeah like I
could see like a place like Newark or
like somewhere you know what I mean like
bed style like some place it's already
there that's nice
now you got to go further out on the
Long Island you need a murder robot
that's the 80s in me uh you maybe you
know like there's the gradual place of
like all right we're close to robot
let's just go robot but San Francisco I
don't understand how they're allowing it
I was in a hotel that had a robot and I
was so [__] annoyed what was it doing
in it wouldn't [__] let me close the
elevated door I had no choice that it
had to get on the elevator with me it
overrided me going like that I'm already
in a subservient position to this
[__] thing I just wanted I should
have just tipped the [__] thing over
I really should have yeah pick it up and
why didn't I didn't throw it down the
stairs was its job to it was like
housekeeping I don't know what it was
doing no but it was like the president
was in town and everybody had to stop
hold the elevator
I was just in a fancy hotel in New York
where they had the old school elevator
attendant in the elevator just standing
there and uh what floor was Sir the 34.
thank you I said it's late it's midnight
aren't you going home nowhere 24 hours
we're 24 hours wow how many people are
left in the elevator operator re uh
Union like seven guys left like one guy
in Des Moines one guy in New York it's
like there should be a robot doing that
job that should be a robot yeah it's um
I stayed Uptown for the first time in a
long time
normally I'm downtown because the
seller's downtown going down kind of guy
you're a creative guy yeah and just you
know put on my Beret I hang out downtown
Tommy Warhol yeah just just walking
around Soho checking out the Nike store
broken long European cigarettes and then
I stayed uptown at like 61st and fifth
right on the park it's like this is a
whole different New York this is on the
whole what is that one place what is New
York like no it's uh it's back baby it's
it depends it depends where you go baby
it depends where you go it's back like
what like the way it was when we were
there well no no it's not the Golden Age
where you could ride the Subway at two
in the morning by yourself and no no I
mean when we got there when we got
closer to when we got there yeah when
Giuliani put that [__] right before
Julian dropped down in uh uh Washington
Square Park and and Thompson Square Park
is just all like a tent city and just
just mowed it down and cleaned it up and
took the squeegee guys off the cars
right before like it's it's that like
when we moved in I don't know when I
moved in like I couldn't
park my car with stuff in it on the
street and unload I had to have a friend
stand guard yeah buy the car at the car
because people would steal it
immediately they would bash your window
and steal immediately and it's kind of
back to that it's like all that old
Instinct we you could forget about for
the next 10 15 years right the Subway's
late at night and leave your car open
with your stuff in it and there's no
problem
it's back it's back to what it was like
all those old but let me you know okay
so all those old rules are back yeah but
are the crowds better then
were the crowds better well because you
know they went there when when I did uh
when I did I did uh Pete's movie in 2019
like I had one of the like those that
summer was [__] brutal because you're
just doing sets in front of those those
groaners yeah I mean it was just [__]
it was just yeah no when I think about
it like when I always envisioned myself
as an older comic I I envisioned myself
being the corny old guy
I didn't think that I would be shocking
people in their 20s when I was in my 50s
like they would be going ah dude
whatever happened to Lawrence well it's
hilarious
because they're they're under that whole
like scrutiny of the [__] camera yeah
all the time you know right like uh
you've seen people just video like I
went out to a restaurant last night and
there was this woman just videoing going
in and I was just like trying to get it
like like if it's really just [__]
rude man what are you doing just like it
was [__] hilarious like
like I mean she was making like a
documentary yeah I had a woman I was at
Elton John's last show at Dodger Stadium
and the woman in front of me she's like
uh in her like 50s with her new
boyfriend you could tell it was like two
divorced people going out and John and
the thing and she was doing the same
thing video she was Elton John was
secondary to her to her contact yeah and
she one point turns like Elton John's
behind her right I'm I'm you're me right
right and she's here watching the show
and at one point she turns with her cell
phone and it's right in my face so she
could film herself with her boyfriend
with Elton John in the back she's
literally Bill holding it I'm not
exaggerating this is where the camera is
right in my face I'm like what Elton
John does she doesn't give a [__] about
Elton John she definitely doesn't care
about me I know people are just they're
in their own mood would you miss the
front kick
from a man to a woman at a concert and
nothing happened
right before between the [__] titties
just a reminder that there's other
people in the [__] world
that was brutal but when I think about
going to in those days when we were like
at the comic strip and stuff I was
thinking about uh red red Johnny and the
round guy oh yeah or fat Johnny yeah red
red Johnny like that era like when the
comics were the most inappropriate and
the crowd was into it we all just knew
it was just chaos and fun like when you
think about those two he's just
destroyed just destroy and it was just
an Italian oh there's and it was just it
was Madness it was I I didn't miss those
days I don't know I think I if I was in
my 20s I would think it'd be cool living
the city but as you get older you know
what I mean I didn't win fights when I
was younger I don't need to be like in a
dangerous city in my 50s no it's just
like I am just gonna you know I had an
old bad moment on the subway huh on the
subway it was raining and it was 10 30.
I was going from the cellar down to Soho
and I'm like I'll just take the train
it's hard to get cabs I just went down
just as the train was leaving on the
west fourth so the only people I was
Bronson down there it was like I should
have been playing Charles Bronson but it
was me felt more like Bernard Getz yeah
right exactly fumbling with his pockets
adjusting his glasses and it was like
five kids like 18 19 20 just [__]
[__] up like kicking over garbage cans
and like throwing [__] they just wanted
to they were just like kind of raging
and wanted to mess stuff up and I'm the
only and I'm like Oh my and I just kind
of hey hey now pick up that Barrel we
don't do that around here and I went
literally like behind the pole you know
exactly and just kind of hung out and
the next train came I got on immediately
it was the wrong train took me to the
wrong place it was the right train it
was the right train it's the right train
get the [__] out of there that's 10 30.
it's 10 30 at night on like a Thursday a
Wednesday and I was like yeah this isn't
I'm not gonna win these fights down here
it's like don't take fighting for my
life the trash can yeah no my library I
mean they were if they got if they saw
me
they probably would have you know let's
[__] with this guy too you know what I
mean like
it was I was the first time well it
lasted it was but it was kind of if you
were white it was a nice time it was an
illusion it was it was an illusion it
was it was that's like kind of
whitewashed the whole [__] Island and
they checked they just turned it into a
bunch of like glass Towers
but I always remember like oh like Marin
and people being like I missed 42nd
Street the way it was and everyone would
have talked yeah but all we do is
romanticize how the [__] it used to be
and then it comes back and you're like
look yeah I don't think so yeah it
wasn't that [__] cool yeah right
exactly no I never like when 42nd Street
was the way it was I [__] hated that
place oh that place was just it was just
jizz on everything it was [__] gross
I still walk through there just going
like this gotta be jizz left they just
has to there's no way you could scrub
30 years of people rubbing one out down
there there was a lot of awful things
off about it so
um anyway uh you get you're not gonna be
going
out on this tour I always feel like I
gotta have the whole new thing even if
it's [__] I feel like it's got to be an
hour of me just saying new things yeah
just like different things you don't
have like the guilt of this is
one time they're gonna see me in two
years and I have to give them a great
show well my my thing is if they come
out and see me and I'm already I'm still
doing [__] from what they already saw
that they're gonna be like rip off boo
saw it on Netflix what the [__] yeah
yeah
I know but what's your opinion on people
that jog in the street
with jeans on or with no workout clothes
jog in the street when there's a
perfectly fine sidewalk you know but
they want this smooth pavement and they
jog it's already got the [__] bike
riders out there yeah the Tour de France
thing yeah now you got these [__]
running down like a third of the way out
and I gotta like [__] like yeah
either stop because there's a car coming
like why won't they run on the [__]
sidewalk I don't understand it either
and I I don't understand like if you are
going to be running like that why aren't
you head to toe in reflectors and lights
like as someone who's got Mr I want them
to die yeah but not while I'm driving
I'm like Mr Magoo already with my my
vision is so Mr Magoo I'm gonna run some
[__] dunk down the L.A River they got a
whole [__] Trail I know you can run
down there you know what's down there
the crazy homeless people
so you go down there you become a food
source
you get drowned in two inches of water
please safe
you know evidently I believe home should
be where you and your family feel safest
especially over the holidays with some
fat bastards gonna come down your
chimney
uh this season give yourself and your
family the gift of peace and protection
with the number one rated home security
system Simply Safe and right now Simply
Safe is offering my listeners 40 off a
new security system don't put this off
you know unless you want to I don't want
to tell you what to do but you know you
might want to make your family safe
Simply Safe was named the best home
security system of 2022 by U.S news and
world report for a third year in a row
it's a dynasty in an emergency 24 7 uh
professional monitoring agents use fast
protect TM technology exclusively from
SimpliSafe to capture critical evidence
and verify the threat is real so you can
get priority police response Simply Safe
as a whole home security with Advanced
sensors for every room window and door
HD security cameras for inside and out
smarter ways to detect motion that uh
Jesus Christ smarter ways to detect
motion that alert you only when a threat
is real relax is just a squirrel
oh he's adorable
um and even Hazard sensors that detect
fires floods and other threats to your
home 24 7 Professional monitoring
service costs under a dollar a day
less than half the price of adt's
traditional professionally installed
system with the top rated SimpliSafe app
stay in complete control of your system
anytime anywhere I'm with this um
unlocked for a guests access your
cameras or adjust system settings don't
miss your chance for massive savings on
my favorite security system get 40 off
any new system at simplysafe.com
[Music]
there's no safe like SimpliSafe and
lastly but not leastly
the one and only
stamps.com
the holidays are here
yeah uh right now right about now
seasonal excitement or dread is really
starting to settle in especially for
small businesses
slaying through the office to the post
office inbox more like a blizzard than a
winter wonderland rushing to send cards
and gifts to your local clients uh it's
not too late to get your holiday mailing
and shipping under control with
stamps.com sign up now and you'll be
printing your own postage in minutes
you've heard me talk about stamps.com
they've been sponsoring the show for
over nine years now and if you haven't
tried it the [__] are you waiting for
stamps.com is one is a One-Stop shop for
all your shipping and mailing needs get
access to the USPS and UPS Services you
need to run your business right from
your computer no lines no traffic no
hassle man
um and if you're running an online store
stamps.com Works seamlessly with all
major shopping carts and marketplaces
the holiday season this holiday season
trade late nights for silent nights and
get started with stamps done
stabs.com today [__] I need to go and
get glasses sign up with promo code Burr
for a special offer that includes a
four-week trial plus free postage and a
free digital scale no long-term
commitments or contracts just go to
stamps.com uh Click the microphone and
stop at the home page and enter Burr
b-u-r-r it really is [__] nuts
um what was what what the [__] was the
last 20 years in this country where
everything just became shiny and new
and then it was just like a [__] a
pandemic we come out the other side and
every city is becoming like [__]
Escape From New York you know but it's
Global it's not just here it's Global
it's everywhere you go is just and look
how the government's stepping in helping
people out look how they can just step
right up to the plate
just you really uh you really are on
your own yeah you are on your own I will
say during the pandemic I own I
understand people that hoard guns
food and they had like the place where
they were going to go underground how is
your prepping do you do you are you
prepped for what for the end for the end
times like do you have a couple cases of
water or anything no I'm just gonna kill
myself I'm gonna take a few people out
with me
right take a few people out you know I
got a couple of hockey sticks I can do
some damage and then I'm gonna uh yeah
just kill myself yeah in front of me I'm
gonna watch ESPN right until it goes off
the [__] air like well I guess I
didn't prepare
that's it go ahead I go I don't give up
the ranch it's all yours guys you want
to eat squirrel meat and whatever human
you can find you want to live good luck
you want to rebuild this yeah I don't
got it in me long live the 90s
I'm more 80s I didn't like the 90s to me
I wasn't into the 90s the way a lot of
people were well 90s but you were you
were becoming a great comedian in the
90s that was like no no no I was become
a community who's learning how to handle
being able to do a 20-minute set yes but
I mean I mean you weren't great sweating
but you were like
starting when did you start you started
I started in March of 92 92. yeah a year
before Pete Davidson was born yeah I was
93. so the 90s we were too busy working
you know what I mean the 80s you were
[__] around and being like a fun kid
I remember the 90s walking down the
street to go do spots at the store and I
would see everybody on the Upper East
Side on dates out in these restaurants
yeah just thinking like God I would love
to do that I wish I was doing that right
yeah but thank God I didn't yeah no
kidding because I'd be divorced and
miserable I'd be one of those people
yeah my kids would be in their 20s
hating me yeah you know I know yeah
because everybody that I looked at yeah
it looked like none of it worked out
none of those people's lives not one
that's how it works for me not one I did
the right thing I kept walking by myself
to do my dick jokes it's true I agree
with it like I walk through Soho all the
time like from the hotel to The Cellar
and I still you do have those little
pangs like you see people it looks
fabulous the lights are nice people are
ordering stuff it's fabulous if you're
with somebody you love yeah going out to
dinner there's nothing better that's
better than going out of the [__]
yeah
Club it is yeah did you ever go to a
club we both had a giant void that we
were trying to film with this empty
business
oh
no at this point like uh
look at me I get my old man's sweater on
dude I am so steering into getting older
that's the best I can't wait you know
what I got glasses my glasses I'm gonna
[__] out old you no way I'm gonna
look at it no no you're Classic you're
like a classic like you just need a pipe
right now you could be on the cover of
TV Guide 1956
America's dad Tom Papa I mean I was
excited to come here and spend some time
with you and this is fun and all but the
really the thing that's really excited
me is that on the way back home I can
pass the Train Shop in Burbank is there
a train shop yeah he's into model trains
and it's uh it's and yeah Christmas I
set up the whole village and stuff and
uh it's insane like it it looks like the
beginning of a movie like if you if you
drone shot that you wouldn't you
wouldn't know that it wasn't a real City
and a train yeah and you were there in
the very beginning when we first moved
out here and had the first like house
and the first you were the you saw the
beginnings of the village yeah I thought
that was really cool it was just like we
had one house and like a train going
around and yeah it was like my dad
collects trains like though like the the
ones from like 70 years real heavy ones
yeah all metal like uh he knows the
names of them and all of that type of
stuff yeah he'll drive two states away
you guys really Santa Fe [__]
something
that's amazing yeah Billy Gardell gave
me a uh a train because it was he's
really into trains like he doesn't do it
just for the holidays he just does it
all the time like he has he looks like
he drives a train
I could totally see him in that totally
with the lantern
hanging off the side I I buy that the
best and he gave me trains just because
it was the route in New Jersey that I
would be familiar with where I grew up
oh he's into it like like he knows like
the lines and yeah all of it so I can I
can stop at the train and I really think
for like skipping all of the fancy
dinners and stuff and going into this
weird but to be able to like I was just
on a random afternoon when other people
are working as grown-ups I could be in a
train shop looking for extra track and
hey how about how much is that stop
light
you're gonna be that weirdo that goes
into a train shop on a [__] Tuesday
afternoon it's the best it's the best
you dude you walk in dressed how you are
they're like dude we got a live one
we're making a rent now
this is a man with time on his hands
have you seen the new snow covered trees
do tell oh anybody young if anybody
young watches this I'm telling you
getting old is [__] incredible it's
[__] incredible like the amount of
[__] you not only do you not give a [__]
about anymore you don't even have to
there's a few people in their 20s like
if you see like old souls in the 20s
they're like some of my favorite people
ever they already get it yeah right
exactly I was never that into like doing
the stuff you know you weren't a club
guy you weren't the guy that went out
and go [__] hit the VIP things bottle
service I can honestly say without any
exaggeration have never been in a club I
think that's a good thing but never that
is an unbelievable Fall From Grace when
you get to be our age like if you were
actually the guy that went into those
clubs like John Travolta yes clearing
the dance floor right banging the
hottest ass in the city yeah to then
just be in your 50s with the dad Bond I
mean that's like astronauts when they
come back to Earth and they just start
crying at a stoplight
sweater on just you know I kind of
rolled off a curve yeah I'm like oh this
is nice being 54. since I was in college
I've been going to the same bars like it
looked like it should have been closed
10 years ago there's one Irish guy at
the end an old jukebox like those shitty
but like that I actually sort of low-key
look at some of those guys the guys that
used to [__] do their sets and then
stand out in front of the cellar
literally looking like Bears when Salmon
was swimming Upstream waiting for girls
trying to grab chicks as they came up
the [__] stairs yeah and I always
look at them just wondering now that
there's and you see there's another
young they don't really do that anymore
though do they not as much they're not
they're not as uh I mean there are but
it's not to the level of like it's just
like Chad Jehovah now this this this
this written text this [__] pictures
this video yeah ndas yeah there's the
whole thing now so I don't know I don't
know how they go that's fascinating to
me like I feel like yeah well I feel
like [__] hounds now have to be almost
like Tom Cruise Cruise level in like
mission impossible as far as like how do
you navigate yeah but you know what it's
how do you navigate the kind of woman
that actually would bang a comedian
after seeing a show well that's what uh
that's not a [__] stable personality
no it's not
but it's almost like uh it's almost like
the Middle East where they where they
play by these rules in public where it's
really strict and you can't do anything
and then they go to like the hotels the
safe zones and they go completely nuts
and they can do whatever they want and
drink and drug and stuff and then they
go back into it it's like everyone's
playing by these rules of it being
really that happens in the Middle East
yeah yeah yeah
like if you go when I was in Dubai I
know I was gonna say you're doing gigs
in Dubai yeah I did uh Dubai in Lebanon
and they they have like you can't even
hold hands with a girl on the street in
Dubai and you can't drink
if you go to the hotel where they're
accepting people from around the world
you can go down and all these young
people are doing everything like going
nuts and it's the same thing with like
sex you know what happens when they
leave if they stumbling out and they're
on something they don't uh they skin
them alive just don't hold hands just
don't hold them yeah
but here it's like there's like that's
this real strict puritanical thing and
like we and everybody's like
fighting each other and whatever but do
you think that people are on Tinder then
people are like people are on Tinder
just going and still meeting up and just
having random sex you know what I mean
like there's two realities that they're
playing in
like I have a couple opening acts and
the whole time they're just back on on
Tinder and just random sex
that's what they do yeah you don't need
to stand no oh I'm an idiot no I'm
literally thinking about getting women
like the way we used to like hand out a
business cards I have a website live and
in person and talk to them dude they're
like Michael Douglas in uh that movie
Don't Dance you're like it's like a cast
in a Broadway show for your dick that's
amazing yeah and then they just they
have it all lined up they have it all
lined up [__] God bless you young
people that's how you use the technology
I don't think I would have been good
with that oh come on Tom right yeah no
you know what I always win long term
long term
this is this is a safe vibe that you put
out that some women I think are looking
for a safe Vibe like they yeah they just
are you watching White Lotus you watch
White Lotus yes I am you know that that
is like the show if you're married to
watch with your wife yeah uh do you
watch the like that like that kid like
the young kid from Stanford like being
too nice
oh yeah yeah yeah you know what I mean I
think he's going to kill somebody I
think he's gonna you think he's gonna be
the one who snaps I think he's gonna
[__] snap right I think he's got a
lot of [__] rage and he just sort of
sits there and he just keeps allowing
himself to get trampled on and I just
think or
they're leading me down that road
deliberately because he's like just so
he's but he's too nice he's teetering
there's a thing like too safe
one of these shows I was watching oh I
know that that drum movie where the guy
was screaming at him the whole movie you
know I I rode with that kid for eight
minutes and then after a while I'm just
like just quit the [__] band yeah get
out of it how many groupies he had
playing in some 40 piece Jazz Orchestra
don't join a [__] cover band [__]
this guy not my temple I don't give a
[__]
I don't give a [__] about this Glenn
Miller [__]
you need his approval yes 20 minutes
into that movie I'm like leave now leave
tell me go [__] himself and then I yeah
and then I didn't like in the end he
finally does say go [__] yourself right
spoiler alert by playing really well and
then the teacher kind of smirks like
yeah that's why I was pushing you and
I'm like you abusive [__]
let him have his this victory
yeah so um yeah so anyway wow you were
saying that I haven't set a flashback to
Manny Dorman you did yeah because I made
him hopping mad one time oh yeah he was
literally going [__] you you [__] he
was coming up this guy was like he was
almost like seven what did you do was it
about Israel
no it was about uh Manny Dorman the
owner of the comedy cell yeah the
originator oh them [__] block and the
other clubs
yeah
that they they give you it didn't work
if you were like I had one spot at nine
o'clock maybe like can you do it for me
the 9 23. I'm not gonna make it you can
make it and then next week that's one
spot at like 1205. can you do the 11 40.
I gotta be Uptown you can make it they
would test your life yeah so I started
talking to other Comics like yeah yeah
it happens to me all the time whatever
yeah so then like an idiot I brought it
up to him to Manny yeah with my big
conspiracy theory oh no I'm like
everybody knows you're doing it you just
started I don't know what happened it
just escalated and then he was just
going [__] you you [__] [__]
oh my God this guy's gonna die
and then but it was classic Manny though
yeah I came down like three days later
and I was standing there I was doing the
Irish thing I'm not going to talk to you
he just looked at me just goes just kind
of laughing back and I laughed the best
and I was like all right all right I saw
him rip apart someone it was a dinner if
someone it was an
israeli-palestinian debate oh that was
the easiest way to get him going and
this what did you guys kind of do to the
Palestinians what
[Laughter]
right he would give you books paper
articles yeah he would want you to read
about the issue just so that he could
yell at you yes learn about this so I
can yell at you because he had no one to
debate with
we were all there just talking about
nonsense we had no idea what was going
that guy was the [__] best and what I
loved about him was he loved to argue he
loved to debate and the books he got me
were amazing and we got a big debate one
time I was talking about Columbus saying
he discovered a country where there was
already people there and he actually
argued the other side he goes well you
could you could come to New York and you
could come down stumble to this club and
tell your friends at home I discovered
the comedy seller and I would be like
all right Manny but what if I started
taking credit for the comedy seller and
all that yeah
this big long debate
didn't end up with him because I read I
read a people's History of the United
States probably because I watched uh
no no I actually read it before my
brother told me about that book and then
I saw it mentioned in Goodwill Hunting
um oh right when he rips them apart yeah
when they had like the other side of of
uh whatever the other side's version
yeah of like what happened which are
always those are my favorite books to
read yeah the uh really you like the
people having a contrarian view on
things
no I just thought because I feel like
then you're kind of able to be like all
right yeah no there is you know and try
to figure out kind of like what happened
I mean I only read one book this year
just one well you've been busy well I
mean it's like a real book I mean I read
a couple of comedians books I don't know
but like those are like easy reads
because I I like the people right and
it's fun and I relate to it yeah but
actually getting like oh let me read a
book about stand-up comedy right I can
get through it like no problem if I
could read like smart books like that
yeah what about on tape what about when
you put them on in your car I feel like
that's cheating I know but I think I
think that's an old guy thing I think uh
you know uh Gary Goldman signed off on
it a real man puts on glasses yeah and
he's a big reader puts on a fire and he
sits down and he reads he reads I know
but uh yeah you're still getting it
you're still getting the information
just saying while you're driving around
because you're busy but when you're in
your car you listening to nonsense
listen to books I just feel like I'm a
child like somebody's reading like a
Bedtime Story Once Upon a Time I just
know I'm gonna there was a group of
people here before Columbus and you keep
rebinding it what'd he say what'd he say
is that what you do yeah I don't do it
I'm just saying this is a theory I I'm
like you I feel like you should read it
I feel like it is I feel like I get more
it's it's like I'm listening to a movie
rather than uh
The Experience no I worry about my brain
turning a mush you know so I figure you
know you got to like kind of like uh put
the work in
um as opposed to embracing new
technology that makes it easier yeah and
plus I've only read one book this year
it was a good book though it was it yeah
it was called uh Wilmington's lie the
Insurrection of 1892 in the rise of
white supremacy made everything so much
[__] make sense about how the [__] we
got to this point where two people can't
talk without screaming and yelling at
each other and uh
and all all of that stuff right right to
the Insurrection the whole [__] thing
right it's like oh oh really yeah and
then it all makes sense I suppose like
can you what is going on this is crazy
out of no way yes right it's like no
this is just incrementally been moving
in this direction uh interesting
granted I only read one book and I
didn't read any counterpoints so I'm
like this is the one that makes it now
I'm gonna formulate all my opinions off
of this yeah
um yeah other than that I've just I'm
just being a dad I don't have [__]
time to do any of that other other [__]
yeah it's a lot it's a lot it doesn't
have have this time to just you're
almost an empty nester at this point I
know
I know
I'm kind of going to ratch up the
boozing
what are you gonna do I don't know I was
thinking of spending more time in New
York like
going and like spending maybe three
months there rather than just bopping in
and out and and I was like you know
we're gonna be free and my kids might
both be on the East Coast going to
school it's like that's [__] we can
do whatever we want why don't we just go
get an Airbnb and go back to living in
New York where we came from for like
three months
um but what we didn't think about was
that the dogs will still be alive
and uh just when I get out yeah we've
got these two dogs and a cat who all
need care and dump them off at a shelter
that's what I'm well yes
I used to do it I have a lot of
solutions my wife is not into any of
them so it might the animals might
what's gonna kill you is the cat the cat
dude having a cat's like having a kid
that never moves out I mean those
[__] things will run for like 30
years and go forever I know yeah we have
a pug and we have a black lab and uh
they're all healthy and young so we're
kind of I don't know what's gonna do
even though I never seen the movie I've
just heard the reference enough you
gotta do a Hunger Games
with the animals that's why you gotta go
with fish whoever lives gets to come to
New York yeah fish would be good why
can't you just bring the pets with you
yeah maybe because then you got to get a
stinky Airbnb that someone else had
their cat and dogs in exactly and now
you have this black lab that even in our
house you know with a yard it feels
cluster from Menagerie
children they all want pets and they
want pets and you got chips
two kids you got three animals two kids
three animals yeah and uh they just kept
wanting animals and they keep bringing
them in my kids want a dog and I'm all
for it my wife's like no it's it's
brutal they become instantly the most
important part of the house who the
animal the dog
the dog has to be walked the dog has to
wakes up the dog it everything all of
the energy goes to the animal it's
amazing they're the the dumbest one in
the house and they get all the attention
and you have to bend your whole schedule
for the animals we'd have friend my
friend Aaron's greatest argument to not
get a pet don't do it don't do it I'm
telling you don't do it don't end up
like me man don't do it I guarantee you
that you will not think that the love
you get from this animal is equal to is
worth the work no way so you resent your
dogs yes I'm plotting to do you like the
cat because it's more independent yeah
I do I hate cats no I like them but I I
don't want him in my house
why
uh
uh I've talked about this I don't like
how if you turn around you catch them
practice and killing you I don't like
how they stalk you they do it they never
really make them
they'll never do it there was a chick in
my neighborhood
that I went to [__] in school with she
told me she's like you remember old lady
so and so she died
you know when she was alone she died in
her house the cat [__] ate her face
well well it waited
but dog would have just sat there and
starved
out of the toilet that would have been
it I don't have animals you've got
you've got you've got
you can go visit animals you can bring
them to petting zoos you can go to the
farmer's market and have them pet the
goats don't bring them into your house
if I was gonna get if in a perfect world
I would get a goat a goat I love goats
they [__] non-stop yeah but they stare
outside I think outside you know what I
like and you know what I like about them
I like that they like to Rough House
it's a great way to get energy out like
you [__] push them and like
like [__] come back at you man yeah I
like those things they actually enjoy it
I went on the orange what can you sing
like they get like oh you wanna my
sister has they just stink my sister's
high school they stink and they're
weirdos they get sideways eyes and
you'll just have sideways they have the
eyes on the side of their head no they
don't their pupils go sideways oh that
black part it goes like yeah they're
weird and you just walk up on them and
they're all of a sudden standing on top
of their house for no reason
foreign
yeah I uh yeah I don't know if you have
if you're if you have a homestead and
you can let them out and they can run
for a quarter mile or if you want to get
a tax break like somebody I know they
went out they just got chickens and
goats and [__] so they could be
classified as a farm and they wouldn't
have to pay as high property tax
yeah
my sister has chickens it's pretty good
you get all those fresh eggs
I think chickens are great yeah chickens
are great and there's something about
them that you know yeah I just but then
you know then you start attracting all
these predators that you didn't even
know exist like stunts and [__] like
what the [__] is that thing that you've
seen those things like those minks no
stoats and these [__] I've never
heard they jump on I don't know I don't
even know if I'm saying it right all
right it's sort of like an ugly Minx and
it [__] jumps on the back of a rabbit
and just starts biting down oh and the
rabbit's going like yeah oh [__]
horrible
it's [__] horrible dude there there
is no God
do you watch those animal videos there's
just no God there's no they just what
the [__] do you ever watch the praying
man he created these [__] things that
can't even defend themselves yeah and
their whole job is just to be eaten
and then these monsters just come out
do you ever see a praying mantis videos
oh my God this praying mantis putting a
[__] bro oh my God it's just not
necessary that's why if I if I had to
choose any death any death without a
doubt it's a cat big cat just come up
they just no they just grab you you go
oh yeah they [__] grab you and then
you're [__] out and then they just
sit there until your heart starts
beating and then they eat you as opposed
to a bear that's like they just [__]
just ripping you apart as you're alive
do you ever see a tarantula eat
yeah those [__] oh there's a pet store
near here and we went inside right next
to the trail shop it is it's time it's
got a lot of free time it is right by
the cobbler
and they had a tarantula mounting a
mouse and it had stunned the mouse and
it just like lowers this like this two
alien and just starts sucking out the
insides of the of the mouse oh just on
just in a imagine walking in and seeing
that in a case and be like how much for
him
dude there's like pbn oh my God yeah I I
do the worst one ever is the uh is that
what's that [__] giant lizard the
monitor no no no
Komodo dragon yeah I have nightmares
thinking about that thing what the [__]
what does that do to you oh those
[__] things those [__] things you
want to talk about just eating somebody
alive don't ever watch a Komodo dragon
ever really they first of all their
saliva is just so [__] toxic they
bite you then they just back off knowing
you're gonna die within the next 24
hours and then just sit there like
slowly following you around and then
when she when you can't stand up anymore
of course you're not dead that's not the
way he wanted it you gotta just sit
there and then the thing just comes in
usually goes for your belly and just
starts eating yourself so you could
watch it
like watching a colon flapping out of
the [__] thing's mouth I mean dude it
is just like oh my God there is no
um God there is no God if you watch
nature like you're supposed to like you
know you get close to Nature you sense
God I don't I don't
since parent is the best I'll give that
guy
like why would you create this oh it's
awful don't get pets for your kids
don't do it you have enough burden you
there's no way you will you will never
even be able to listen to a book on tape
like there's no books in your future if
you have an animal in addition to what
you already have in your house
I think you've been a little hard on
dogs
they're you got two of them I know and a
cat you [__] up dude when I you liked
one of those guys in Utah that marries
three women
one is enough what are you doing yeah
this wasn't my design there's nothing I
had no participation in this at all
none you couldn't put your foot down no
put some bass in your voice no take your
glasses off no throw your [__] yeast
across the kitchen
tell them I'm not giving him any more
bread no there was no and look the prob
this is the weakness and you're gonna
you're gonna be you were going to be
challenged
over the next 15 years it's like of
seeing the joy in their eyes and your
your little kids just like can we please
and knowing if you say yes the The Joy
you're going to create in these little
people when you say they're gonna love
that dog for so much for 20 minutes
exactly it's gonna last as long as the
you saying yes and then it's gonna be
your problem but you can make them so
happy and I gave in and I was like oh
it's gonna make her happy and it does
make them happy how long you makes them
so happy
uh we've had one for about five years
and one for about three
we got a pug during the pandemic and it
uh hugs go for like what 12 13 years
yeah
yeah we uh our neighbors sleep apnea
though so you remember you know I know
but it's our neighbor just had one die
and it was like 15 and she was like oh
they're so cute but Rob but pugs right
my wife's like what do you mean with her
the Bri they like to sleep a lot she's
like no the medical bills for the last
eight years so many problems they've got
so many problems I was like I wasn't
even thinking about that I was just
pissed that I got to put diapers on it
because of the keys in our house
your problem
please do that's why I'm here two
letters in one word
LA River
that's where he came from
they found him on the LA River because
somebody else so he was peeing on
someone else's Furniture I'm not dealing
with this it's like the What About Bob
pet and you just [__] picked it up
no I uh no I I mean the joy they are all
in love they all like it they all have a
great time with it but what
all right let's go to New York let's go
to New York for three months that'll be
great let's go the girls are gone let's
go who's gonna take care of Frank and
Bella
all right well I guess we'll just sit
here then and watch Frank and Bella
oh no yeah
that's what's waiting for me is your
wife all right with that
I don't know she loves them oh she does
love them she loves them in a deep she
loves them no joke more than me like she
loves them more than she loves me do you
think because she gets to do that
motherly thing because they need them
yes maybe if you were a little more open
and vulnerable oh yeah 100 [__] on the
carpet every once in a while she'd love
you
if I cried once in a while and acted
like I needed help yeah it would
definitely work your wife doesn't want
to see a cry you're allowed to cry at a
funeral that's about it
I don't know I cried I cried when my
daughter was going away to college it
was like two days before that's taking
her that's fair and I was in bed and it
just washed over me that this was over
this part was done this little our whole
life was built just for her
for both of them and now she's gone and
she's not and she's not coming back and
it just washed over me I started crying
in bed I was just like my wife I never
saw my wife so happy
I never saw her so he is human
she was overjoyed there was something
about watching me crumble that really
made her and then because then when it
was over she kept like poking me over
the next month like can you believe
she's gone
and just look at me waiting for it to
happen again why is that the one of the
only emotions that's like valid yeah you
know what I mean right like you could be
jovial happy-go-lucky blah blah
you know what because that's the one
because you know there's a shame as a
man yeah they're crying yeah yeah you're
weak you're broken
and I know one time I really really
cried in front of my wife was a friend
of mine got murdered and uh and then I
remember that yeah like they actually
like wow man they actually [__]
you do feel feelings I know
the problem is took us all these years
yeah I was watching all this [__] on TV
and um
uh she would be crying and I would be
laughing I just talked about this on
Conan but I would just be laughing
and she would get uh
she would laugh too like why are you
laughing I don't know it's just funny
watching her cry no just watching the
people crying it was you know oh yeah
yeah I you know watch the Conan Potter
all right
well the weird part too like as
there's a lot more reasons to cry I'm on
the edge of crying all the time since
I've had children I think a lot of men
are on the edge of crying but for a lot
of their life and we just push it down
and you push it down and unless you're
in the car and you're not at a stoplight
yeah right and you can squeeze a few
tears out the problem is like if you
because we hold it in so much if you do
let it out like my wife my wife could
cry for like three minutes and be like
right back to herself for me to break
down it's gonna be a mess yeah no it's
just like Decades of like
pouring just sweat and tears and crying
and babbling and it's gonna come out
like a tsunami so and I always just
picture your wife just being like you're
right exactly
hey
exactly I know what I wanted by the way
I'm getting no I
um I think I'm all right now I think I
had bronchitis or something I don't know
what I had and you're not even sitting
across me for the better part of 40.
yeah now you tell me but the other part
of it is you know what you don't want to
see your dad crying you don't want to be
like no you can't you don't see your dad
you can never cry in front of your kids
oh you don't want to see your dad at the
end of the bed like holding his head and
His Hands just no you're sweating it out
you can't no you can't do that because
their their sense of security yes is out
the window like they they look at you
like your Iron Man right that you have
to keep up that Fable until you're
[__] walking around with your Walker
and then you can be like it was all
alive
I've been scared since before you were
born
there is no God it's true
um where are we in time do we gotta wrap
this up where are we because I'm seeing
people walking around out there like
they're waiting to get in here okay we
are where are we we are at the end we
went from talking about specials yeah to
uh how to get rid of your pets yeah to
crying as a man yeah is this some of the
topics we can expect from what a day on
Netflix December 13th bringing it back
around it pretty much is what a day I
named it because what a day because well
I always say that in the morning in
front of my kids I'm like what a day
what a day that's how I start the day
off and I like that at the end of the
like around five it's like what a day
that's hilarious it's not in the ACT
anywhere I don't have jokes about it but
it's just my I just oh it's like an
inside joke for you I love [__] like
that yeah in the morning it's what a day
everybody honest oh what a day that's
beautiful five o'clock yeah that was
beautiful that was just [__]
beautiful it was good seeing you be
smoking a cigar with my father and I
sent you that picture and I was like I
miss hanging out with Billy and smoking
cigars well oh Billy uh doesn't smoke as
much as he used to there well if you can
fit it in we should do it more than just
the podcast
um no absolutely I could
um maybe bring your kids over and look
at the trains
they'd like that my son would probably
rip him up but I'm holding it back I'll
hold him at Bay all right the great Tom
Papa always great to see you brother
thanks man look for his new special what
a day what a day what a day on Netflix
December 13th thank you guys for
watching
[Music]
hey what's going on it's Bill Byrne it's
the Monday Morning podcast for Monday
December 8th
2014. what's going on everybody how are
you
um
uh Jesus Christ oh freckles oh freckles
has been [__]
smoking too many cigars and the [__]
booze I don't know what I'm doing
I know what I'm doing you know what it
is I'm ready for my [__] year to be
over
I'm ready to be on vacation I'm burned
out I am burned out from uh
all the crap I've been doing I I don't
work this hard
I'm a comedian
I sit around on the couch all day I I
take up the ukulele
just killing a day waiting for my show
at eight o'clock at night that's what
I'm supposed to be doing
but uh you know I got a couple things
going on I had to promote my special
everybody for those of you uh who didn't
hear I have
my new stand-up special just came out uh
Friday it's on Netflix exclusively it's
exclusively on Netflix it's called I'm
sorry you feel that way and um
got to admit people really seem to be
liking it thank Christ
um I want to thank everybody
you know Netflix new wave Jake Harris
for uh directing it
um giving me the special the look the
one that I wanted
um and people seem to like it
so that's all good it's all [__] good
as far as you're wondering well when can
I yeah when can I see it can I buy it
um Netflix has it for a year one year
from now
When anybody who wanted to see it
already has seen it then I'm allowed to
sell it on DVD Blu-ray or whatever the
[__] I want to do uh
you know
you know the deal so uh that's one and
that's when I'll I'll have it available
that's just the deal that's just how it
is you know
considering uh the current climate on
the internet this is the way you have to
do the deals
because uh you know people [__] steal
them
so if somebody's willing to put the
money up for the special what the [__]
you gonna do plus Netflix works great
for me because I like to try to travel
as far as I can internationally speaking
and uh you know Netflix seems to be
getting more International as we go
along so it's been it's really been a
nice marriage between the two of us but
seriously I got a ton of great feedback
um on my special and uh
I feel it's my best work you know and
now that I've said that you guys can be
[__] and be well actually I saw you on
premium blend and I felt uh the material
combined with your [__] velor shirt
was much better
um
the [__] did I wear on that I think I
had on it I think it was a crushed
velvet [__] green
button up shirt or something like that
and black pants
I can't remember
it was one of those ones where it became
dated I think before the end of my set
um
but uh
you know every once in a while you take
a chance and it doesn't work up I
basically look like I'm in Robin Hood's
like if Robin Hood had an agent like
that's how he would dress
whatever nobody gave me [__] that night
so everyone who watched was also guilty
all right let's plow ahead here so
anyway so I have to take my [__]
laptop over to this place here in my uh
my part of Los Angeles and I take it
over there and the guy figures out what
I need is uh I needed a new hard drive
so he puts the new [__] hard drive in
so this morning I go to you know
download all the information I get all
your questions and whatnot and then make
my list of subjects that I might talk
about I might not talk about so I go to
open up this [__]
is it program app I don't know what the
[__] you call it it's one of the things
we can actually write you know you can
type some [__] on and save it later and
like a document and I open the [__]
thing up and immediately
it's just steering me towards this
SoundCloud [__]
yeah we can save it then you can have it
on all your devices you know have you
ever thought about how [__] dumb you
are if you're using SoundCloud
I'm not even talking about his
convenience the fact that you're just
giving access
to your goddamn life to to God knows
hope
you know what and then you're gonna sit
around and well I can't believe somebody
stole my identity
oh that picture of my dick end up on the
[__] internet's like what are you
doing
don't give people access to your photos
and your files
and all of that [__] because of some
[__] little kid mentality but what if
I lose them
what do you got a [__] balloon tied
around your wrist that's what you got
the backup hard drive for
put them on there and once a week just
[__] send a few over there
and then if something catastrophic
happens to your laptop you still have 98
of your [__] you got to survive
so having said that because anybody know
how to disable that [__] goddamn
cloud
[__] weirdo man [__] creep that's
just like some nerd
like if you looked over and there's just
some nerd standing in your window with
his black frame glasses trying to look
at all your pictures
trying to see uh what the [__] you're
writing about trying to see what
websites you're on the whole thing is
[__] creepy you know what's really
creeping me out if somebody recently is
trying to suggest that the camera that's
on your [__] laptop is on all the
time and potentially somebody could be
watching you or it's recording you or
whatever
um
what the [__] are they going to save all
of that
you know what I mean
although it does kind of freak me out
um
I just I just had a bad week with the
technology everybody I um I am so
[__] anti-all of this [__] and I know
is it I just feel like it's convenient
as it makes your life
is the the amount of [__] uh money it
cost and [__] crashing and then you
gotta upload it and then try to figure
out how to use the new [__] and then
them just just more and more
trying to figure out just spy on you
they're [__] spying on you for
whatever reason to try to sell you more
toothpaste
or to just make sure they got enough
dirt on anybody who ever decides to run
for political office for the rest of
[__] time
do you realize right now
that the next president right not the
next president well some president in
the future say some president in 2040 or
whatever right now is probably getting
videotaped jerking off to something
right
and they're going to have all of that
[__] information
all the [__] creepy [__] you did all
your weird little thoughts
all your insecurities all every [__]
thing they need to know about you to
keep you in line
everybody thinks this is like paranoid
thought I know it's not this word Jay
Edgar you know how much J Edgar Hoover
would [__] love the cloud
that [__] weirdo
used to sit there going around
Washington trying to
just have dirt on everybody
so you can walk up and talk to you and
just know [__] about you who you were
[__] what you were doing if you were
secretly gay or anything and he probably
sat there
talking to you right the weird look on
his face and you'd be like this guy's
just giving me the creeps why is he why
is this guy giving me the [__] creeps
it's because he knows about your life
and he's so excited about it he's
probably [__] his [__] dick it's
probably at half mast as he's talking to
you
you know
J Edgar Hoover
and then they try to say that that guy
actually was uh he used to walk around
in a dress all day
you know I don't understand that
I don't understand why you would want to
walk around in a [__] dress
as a man or a woman not really the dress
I can understand the dress it's like
having a bathrobe that doesn't open
right
wearing one of those [__] things you
know
you're having a smock
I just don't get the shoes why the [__]
would you want to wear I mean they look
good
they look good when the ladies prints
around and what the [__] would you why
why anybody in their right [__] mind
would want to walk around in your tippy
toes
the whole goddamn day [__] up your
back is beyond me and you would think
that if you're a dude you're like oh
good I don't have to wear that [__] to
go out of your way to actually wear it
you know why would you do that to
yourself
you know what if I gotta go and dress up
like a woman but wear some Flats
J Edgar
you know you're gonna [__] slip a
disc you're not you're not exactly in
shape
um anyways this is the Monday Morning
podcast
um
I don't know what the [__] I'm doing
with my life I'm so [__] busy I got
one more acting gig here we're shooting
the FXX pilot this week I'm doing it
this week with the Always Sunny guys
um and I rap next week on Wednesday
all right I wrap next week Wednesday
when I wrap next Wednesday
actually Tuesday night so Wednesday is
gonna be my first just back to being a
comedian again
all right
back to my [__] playing drums
back to my uh uh whatever the [__] else
I used to do going hikes with my dog I
cannot [__] wait and I got two three
weeks
where I'm just gonna chill out
and buy chill out I mean probably do
stand up eighty percent of the nights
because I got to come up with a new act
because I got my big uh
big tours coming up of uh Australia New
Zealand and parts of Asia
parts of Asia
Singapore Hong Kong
Saigon did not work out we're gonna have
to do that on the next one but
um
and then I'm going to some [__] place
in India
I don't know what it is I think it used
it's the place that used to be called
Bombay
let me look it up I think it's there I
shouldn't be saying that [__]
let's see Bombay
India
let's see what it says here
yeah Mumbai I think that's where I'm
going Jesus Christ look at these [__]
pictures
Feast of famine
um
yeah so I'm gonna be doing that I'm
actually a little creeped out to be
flying around
uh Asia and that type of [__] just
because uh I'm reading up on [__]
Aviation and that type of thing just um
I'm just hoping I have the the whatever
plane I'm on the co-pilot when he sees
we're running out of gas doesn't give a
[__] about embarrassing the captain and
says hey dude
I'm not trying to be a dick here I'm not
trying to get out of uh out of line but
uh we're gonna [__] be on the ground
at 10 minutes unless you [__] pull
over at a station
we're running out of gas over here look
I'm not even looking at you I'm not even
looking at you Captain not trying to
disrespect your Authority or suggest
that you're [__] up right now but
you're kind of [__] up right now
all right
I I'm nervous about that other than that
that and getting caned in Singapore I've
been told that you can just kind of do
whatever you want on stage it just
doesn't make sense to me that if I'm in
a [__] country that you can get
arrested for spitting gum on the
sidewalk that I can actually go on stage
and talk the way that I want to talk I
don't know about that
Oh Billy butt cheeks is gonna find out
though
I'm really looking forward to it um
it always uh
you know it's always cool I'm hoping to
actually be able to hang out with the
locals drink a couple of beers shoot the
[__] hear what the [__] they have to say
meet some Comics abroad
yada yada yada see what the [__] goes on
over there that's gonna start up um I
don't even know why don't I go to my own
website and figure it out for you I
actually did yesterday I did four hours
of phoners right in the middle of the
football so I missed a ton of football
but I have to promote these uh I got to
promote these shows and uh call some
places in New Zealand and Australia dude
Australians are [__] hilarious I'm
calling them up and almost every
reporter was going
um so you're touring all of Australia
uh yeah and I'm like yeah pretty much
going across hitting just about every uh
every major city except that one city
that begins with an with an a that I'm
getting a bunch of [__] for for not
going to Adelaide or whatever the hell
it's called
um it just didn't work out
but anyways they all had the exact same
question they would just go and like
yeah I see you know you
you torn over here uh why
they kept asking me why
and I was like I don't know it kind of
seemed like why why not
like why wouldn't I
I don't know they're like have you
read up on anything that's going on down
here do you do you know what's going on
in the news and I'm like no
yes because your act seems really
American I'm [__] American
it's gonna be fine stop getting in my
[__] head I went to Melbourne and
I've been to Sydney and it went fine
the [__] am I supposed to read up on
wombats
just going down there talking about my
life I guess it's going to be hot as
[__] bulls when I get there my first
one is January 27th I'm gonna be at uh
in Perth Australia
and uh
I guess it's gonna be uh could get
upwards of 40 degrees Celsius
now for you those of you in the land of
America is the easiest way to learn
Celsius all right water freezes at zero
Celsius and boils at 100 degrees Celsius
it's really simple all right so you know
water boils at what was it 212 degrees
or some [__] like that so all right
so 100 Celsius is 212 that means 50
Celsius is like about 106 degrees you
just do it that way you just keep
cutting it in half you can roughly guess
whatever the [__] it is so
they said it gets up to about 40 Celsius
so they're talking over a hundred
[__] degrees
oh freckles is uh I wasn't counting on
that I thought it was going to be nice
and balmy
because I've been there in October and
um
it was a little bit chilly sort of fall
type of weather
and uh I guess they were coming out of
there WETA
um I don't know but I'm looking forward
to going to Perth I'm gonna uh Bond
Scott is buried there for my favorite
band ever AC DC so I'm gonna go pay my
respects there they got a statue of them
there I'm gonna walk around Perth for a
day or so get acclimated
to uh
you know the time over there which is
[__] brutal
that would actually be the furthest
uh oh no that actually would be that
would actually be a better
time zone for me
right
because Sydney and Melbourne are further
to the International Date Line that's
closer to it so I'm actually moving
farther away so I actually pick up a
couple hours that's not bad
um sorry doing the math there and then
okay so on January 27th I'll be at the
Perth convention and Exhibition Center
on the 29th I'll be in Melbourne uh Arts
Center
[__] thing
January 31st I'm in Brisbane Brisbane
however the [__] you say it Brisbane
City Hall
on uh February 1st I got two shows at
the Sydney Opera House
and then February 3rd
um in New Zealand February at Auckland
news Auckland town hall and then I'm
doing the Opera House in Wellington New
Zealand
so uh
you know I've heard nothing but great
things about New Zealand too unless you
go to Australia and then they always
make fun of them but it's just like
you're just doing that because you got
nobody else to make fun of down there
it's the closest [__] country right
they're right there so you get to act
like all the [__] yahoos live in New
Zealand
you know
I've driven a little bit of Australia I
drove from [__] Melbourne over to the
uh
the [__] 12 Apostles whatever the
hell they were and uh you know
it got a little hairy there as we were
driving around yeah and so I'm saying
you know you get out there there's a lot
of surfers and that type of [__] but I
mean you know
I don't know Australia's [__] insane
do you realize like the top 10 most
poisonous snakes on the planet are all
in [__] Australia every last [__]
one of them like the inland taipan has
like enough Venom
I mean it would [__] just drop a
goddamn
elephant right it'd bite the elephant
and the Elephant would be like oh what
the [__] was that and then just one bam
down on the ground [__] over and then
that thing would dislocate its jaws and
it could swallow that elephant hole
I'm [__] with you he couldn't but it
could [__] it up kill it
and evidently the reason why they have
that much venom is because food is so
scarce so they have to be even if they
just wing it
you know what I mean it'd be like if a
sniper shot you with a bazooka and just
sort of graced you that would be it for
you you'd be done you'd be finished
so uh I'll be wearing boots the whole
time I'm over there
get away some thigh-high Timberlands
snake proof [__]
um
I don't know I'm sure all the locals
will be yeah actually Mike they're
actually [__] scared of you I don't
give a [__]
I don't give a [__] so uh and I'm trying
I'm actually gonna travel really really
really really really really really light
okay so for all you [__] who are
already going to give me [__] going bill
you wore the same two shirts the whole
[__] tour that's right I did
all right Jim Morrison wore those smelly
brown leather pants for an entire
[__] tour
all right I can't go over there with two
shirts Oh Billy two shirts
one shirt two shirt Red Fish Blue Fish
that's what the [__] I'm doing
I'm gonna have uh two pairs of pants two
shirts and then I'm dressing like I'm on
The Sopranos when I'm on a plane which
means I'm wearing a little [__]
tracksuit and that's it I'm gonna have
my [__] toilet trash with me
and I am not bringing
I'm not checking any [__] bags
but here's the problem I'm traveling
with my lady
and you know how women travel you know
they [__]
you know they [__] they bring a lot
of [__]
why women be bringing all that [__]
sorry
I went into early 90s Def Jam now
um all right let's get to the inbox here
what do we got here let's let's get to
some live reads for this week oh my
goodness everybody
hey by the way I've actually figured out
that I am dyslexic a little bit
I'm not like really bad but I've really
started to pay attention to it and the
way words get jumbled up as I'm [__]
reading them and then I look at a word
and I think it says life but it's
actually file
it's not like the bill like a
debilitating kind of [__] thing but I
I got a little ill you know
you know a little bit a little bit all
right here we go let me get back to the
goddamn questions here for this week
um
what else did I want to talk about too
there was a huge fire last night here in
downtown L.A and it was just I'm pretty
sure it's this apartment complex that
I've been driving by
um
drove by a lot this year I mean those of
you who watch that Seinfeld thing you
guys know that I learned how to fly a
helicopter this year and uh so I would
get up early in the morning and as I was
driving down
you know for my lessons
um
I would [__] drive by this apartment
building that was going up in like two
seconds you know and as I'm sitting
there getting construction downstairs
and that's taking all [__] goddamn
year and I'm watching this thing just
flying I'm gonna granted they got a
[__] 100 person crew or whatever
um
this thing burned to the goddamn ground
and these firefighters talking about it
was hilarious was saying how big the
fire was
was saying that they actually call it
like this was a career fire
you know like a quarterback had a career
day
you know going 35 for 38 for 468 a
career day
these firefighters have like a career
fire
a [__] great an expression that is
that are there any firefighters who
listen to this I want to hear about your
career fire
you know I want to hear some from uh
some firefighters
I want to hear what's the most [__] up
thing you've seen in a fire I don't mean
anything disgusting about death I mean
afterwards
as you're going through the [__]
Rubble
trying to find like what caused the fire
have you ever just found like a safe at
the bottom of it and nobody's claiming
it
you know and then you try to get the fat
[__] from the firehouse the guy who
makes the chili to come over there and
try to pick it up and put it in the back
of your [__] Dodge Ram
you know it sounds like a [__] movie
with Billy Bob Thornton
all right we don't tell anybody
ends up being some [__] come on man
you can't tell me every once in a while
you went in there you risked your life
I mean [__] burn into death's got to
be one of the worst deaths ever and you
face that every [__] day you can't
tell me
that when you're rummaging through that
you find you don't find a couple of
Trinkets and be like you know what I
earned this
you stick it in the front [__] lapel
pocket of your heavy duty rubber
raincoat there it's not made out of
rubber right it would melt I don't know
I want to hear some fire stories but I
want to hear about people getting burned
up I don't hear about that [__] but I
just like uh
you know is is the logo are you the low
guy in the totem pole As A Firefighter
where after the big boys put the fire
out yeah the guy's got to sit there
pissing on it for like the next three
days
just standing up there
going back and forth it's got to be the
shittiest job ever there's no [__]
excitement whatsoever
you know what I mean
it's like you know you got the you got
the [__] Maniac who writes the book
he gets to drink whiskey be suicidal and
[__] [__] right and then then you got
the guys the proofreader in the end
got to make sure the past participle
says up with the [__] adverb whatever
the [__] they do
that's what that's what that guy is that
guy's the firefighter equivalent of like
a proofreader
you know
or that guy in the locker room who picks
up all the towels after all the players
[__] rub their balls with them that's
what that is
that has to there's no way
there's no way you're in the starting
lineup at your [__] firehouse and you
got to do that [__] you're not doing
that you're there when there's the
flames
all right
come on you guys break that guy's balls
when he's up there
hey make sure you spray over there I
think I saw a [__] spark or two
um anyways all right let's talk uh
Sports you know what I watched very
little football this week because
I was wrapping up watching uh I was I
was binge watching as the children say I
was watching that uh
that show uh The Killing
um I watched the first two seasons about
a year ago and I started to watch season
three uh the first episode I don't know
what happened I just got busy and what
was cool is uh during the time it took
me to jump back on
um
Seasons not uh season four was shot and
was uploaded so I got to watch the whole
Series so I uh
you know season four only had like seven
episodes so I just kind of was blowing
through those things so I missed a lot
of games I did watch the Seahawks Eagles
game
and uh oh my God [__] Paul verzi is
so goddamn funny man
years ago right he said that um
he said that you know after three games
he said Mark Sanchez was a star
all right
and I said Paul it's been three [__]
games he's a rookie you don't think he's
gonna have that
four game you know four picks in a game
that pick six or whatever he's a rookie
blah blah blah blah classic Paul verzi
he sees a guy out of the gate playing
well and then goes this guy's going to
be the greatest [__] ever right
um so
anyways so the guy you know he
it didn't work out for him I'm not
saying and I'm not by any means saying
that the guy is a uh a bad quarterback
he is he's not a bad [__] quarterback
but but like you know I mean people
acting like you're calling him Sanchez
like he was a franchise quarterback
right so anyways
um so yesterday he's cubing for the
Eagles
and he's having he's having a good game
and [__] versie writes and he finally
admitted that he was wrong about Sanchez
so now this Eagles game he's playing
good against Seattle and he said he goes
dude I may have been right about Sanchez
dude can ball maybe not a star but good
for sure it's just like you see how he
tries to worm out of it
he goes I may have been right
when you said the guy was a star Sanchez
and all that and then he goes maybe not
a star but good for sure and it's just
like dude that's not what you said I
never said Sanchez wasn't a wasn't a
good quarterback
so of course I went back you're the
worst you said he was a star
all right I don't want to [__] get
involved in this we me and verzie went
round and round because you know I did
this week and actually test drove some
[__] cash and I took out that
Mercedes-Benz
station wagon AMG
the biggest [__] sleeper
on the planet dude this car was the [__]
I'm gonna upload some video right the
car like when you go to park the [__]
car
it the steering wheel moves itself like
it has sensors all around the car
so you put it in reverse and it cuts the
wheel automatically
and get you to a certain point you just
control the pedals the gas or the brake
and then you put it in drive and then it
turns it the other way you got to see
this [__] uh
this [__] video I went over there
with a buddy of mine and uh test drove a
couple of [__] cars dude this car was
so [__] badass
I'm driving down the hill and there was
this [__] smoke Shelf as they say on
Barstool Sports walking this dog and the
last time I drove in a I drove by in a
car and a woman locked eyes with me the
entire [__] way before looking away
in horror I can't even remember I think
I was in my college Years
I [__] came down in a [__] station
wagon she should be running the other
way this car was so [__] badass
looking
she [__] locked eyes with me the
whole I couldn't believe it it's like I
went back in time
um
took out one of those and then it took a
different one that was like a four-door
Coupe and uh dude that's the [__] car
that is the car because that is like
it's a Supercar and you can put a bunch
of people in it either you get the sedan
or you get the uh the station wagon and
Paul version just kept I kept telling
Paul how [__] sick the car was and he
just kept going ah it's just a station
wagon I I just can't get by it's like
Paul that's what makes it [__] cool
it's the fact that it is a station wagon
and you'd look like they think the
person's a nerd and that they got their
groceries and a bunch of pacifiers in
there and then all of a sudden he
[__] takes off from the line and his
joke groceries and babies are flying out
the back [__] window
that's what makes it [__] cool
I just can't I can't get past that it's
a wagon I mean it's it's a [__] way
it's like version that's it right there
okay you got yeah you got no Style
anybody can go out in like a Porsche
anybody can like a Corvette anybody can
like a Ferrari there's no thought
process
you know
that's why I like watching shows like
Gas Monkey Garage
right
Go Fast and Loud whatever the [__] it's
called Gas Monkey Garage oh I love
watching that show not when they take a
[__] car that's known to be fast I
like when they take a [__] you know
two-door [__] sedan
like that time they bought uh Casey's
[__] uh 55 Ford
and sold it to my Cuban
that [__] car was so goddamn cool
they did that and they did one a 1950s
Oldsmobile
like I don't to me that that's
I don't know those those are the cars
right the Ferraris and all that that's
like going on stage as a comedian and
telling a dick joke it's a [__] layup
you know people are gonna laugh
I know I don't I got a lot of German
blood meat and what I love about Germans
is what's funny to me about them
is they're really bad about getting
along with other people but you give
those [__] a station wagon and
somehow that thing will go zero to sixty
in 3.6 seconds dude it's a [__] race
car you know station wagons usually have
that seat in the back where people face
the other way this car doesn't have that
that's how fast they're trying to get
this thing to go because it's a weight
issue so they got that thing the [__]
out of there
and um
that is the first time I ever drove a
car both cars that I drove and they have
a dual clutch
and I never thought I would say this but
it just eliminates like back in the day
if you got a sports car and it was an
automatic you were the biggest [__]
[__]
and you the whole car was ruined
you know what I mean like if you bought
a Corvette and it was an automatic
you're just a douchebag like why would
you do that the stick shift is so much
faster
you can slow down by downshifting as you
[__] diving into the goddamn turns
right scaring the [__] out of your
passengers right but now
I mean I didn't even understand the
whole concept of it until like a week
ago I started reading up on how that I
was talking about like a week ago that
whole dual clutch system basically this
is how
[__] psychotic
in a good way these guys out who
designed these cars and I guess a dual
clutch system has been around since the
[__] early 80s I just heard about it
which is not surprising because I'm a
[__]
but basically you know when you're
driving a car right
he's going down the street and you're
hearing it going through the gears
[Music]
am right that little part you know so
you're going when you're in your seat
and then you come off the seat man
you're backing him off the seat man
you're coming off the seat
because the clutch is basically
disengaging with the engine and you and
the engine's still working like a
[__] but for that Split Second
when you push in the clutch and it's in
neutral you the engine's working for
nothing right now
that little sliver of that little Split
Second when you go to shift
um you're losing that Torque from the
engine
so the Dual clutch system eliminates you
coming off your seat
by it puts the odd gears on one side of
the [__] and even on the other and I
don't know how to [__] it switches off
the way it does
but I was driving that car
and I'm listening it going through the
gears and I never came off my seat
and the guy says you can use the paddle
shifters if you want but you'll never be
able to shift faster than the Dual
clutch dude you just step on the gas and
it's like
just [__] go through the gears
it's [__] it's you it's so completely
unnecessary
to have
when you're driving down the street it's
so [__] unnecessary to have when
you're just driving around civilians
that you got to have one
um does that make any sense I am
completely sold
on those cars and I'm I'm glad I went
shopping around and all of that type of
[__] so now I just gotta I gotta save up
to get one which is why
I'm touring all through Australia New
Zealand into Asia
before dude I'm like I'm so [__]
psyched for that tour I am going to lay
waste to that land down there I am so
chomping at the [__] bit to to
[__] do stand up right now and I got
all these goddamn ideas
that I want to work out
um
dude I got I I can't I don't know how to
tell this story without giving away the
joke that I'm doing
but I'm gonna tell you why Joe Rogan is
the greatest [__] dude ever
um I got this bit that I want to do and
and it adds like a physicality thing
like possibly even like a pratful and a
lot of stand-up comics would ever look
at it like oh the pret full let's
[__] hacky or whatever I'm just
looking at it like wait a minute that's
that's part of Comedy man like you got
to learn how to do that [__] so I have
this idea for a [__] joke that would
possibly involve something like that I'm
just kind of playing with it and Rogan's
going like dude what the comedy story
he's going dude you could do you could
totally do that he goes come over to my
house I'll show you how to do it I got
the [__] I got you know he's he's got
like an octagon in his goddamn garage
with all the mats and [__] he goes I'll
show you how to do it in this [__]
Maniac loves comedy so much he's such a
good dude we're backstage at The Comedy
Store and he's doing these [__] roles
from a standing position onto the
[__] floor
and I'm just I'm [__] laughing on
this guy like who the [__] else would do
that
[__] from my not even his own joke
he's showing me how to do it he goes
easy you could just [__] do it like
this
it looks like you fall but you're kind
of rolling into it
he did it so well it's like dude you
want to do the [__] joke but uh
anyway so for my next special you see me
flopping around on the [__] stage
know that it's because Joe Rogan
took the time
to show me how to do that backstage
backstage at The Comedy Store and by the
way Rogan is back at the comedy store
which is the greatest thing ever uh they
you know they had a little uh little
riff there and uh right right as I moved
to LA and um I remember when I first
lived in LA in the late 90s one of the
highlights of going down to The Comedy
Store
uh was seeing Rogan
you know back in the day so I uh last
night I was down there and actually
I was late so I didn't get to say what's
up to him but I actually saw him on
stage that's the first time I saw him in
the uh
the or also not called the original room
um
since the late 90s when I think
I made a couple trips in the 2000s to LA
but I just don't ever remember running
into them
so he was doing Fear Factor
um anyways
what else what else yeah so I hoard
myself out this week uh promoting my
special I did Conan O'Brien this week
and once again I always have a good time
on that show thank you to Conan and uh
Andy and all those guys for uh
laughing when I say something funny and
helping me out when it bombs and um
I think that's I think that's about all
I got for this week oh the Bruins Jesus
Christ Jesus Christ we had a rough
[__] road trip a little tight that
was a rough one you know
um
we lost a couple of close ones to the
Ducks
in the Kings and them just got [__]
hammered
by the San Jose Sharks
I don't know what the [__] I mean I
actually went back and watched it but I
uh
it was two to nothing when I left to go
do some spots and I came back and I just
saw it was like seven to four we lost we
could have seven [__] goals
in two periods but you know you always
you have one of those every year you
have a regular season game where it just
gets away from you and then uh we beat
the coyotes a couple nights later so
we went one and three on the road trip
so we're coming back we got the Chicago
Blackhawks I'll tell you it doesn't get
any easier we got the Blackhawks at home
and I think the wild or something like
that coming up that's another thing
looking forward to over the break
I haven't skated since like September
um
yeah I gotta get back into all my
[__] hobbies and all that [__] so
anyways let's uh
in the uh like wait I gotta read some
questions here because I have another
busy [__] day here all right wife in
labor
a billy black and white face my wife and
I watched your new special on Netflix
last night and then at six a.m this
morning her water broke coincidence
probably not she did not want to watch
it because she was having contraction
contractions and was in pain
and I don't think she laughed once I
cackled like a maniac while she glared
at me for enjoying myself so much I
think the hour and 15 minutes of glaring
caused her to go into labor two weeks
early is that a thing thanks for the
entertainment and go [__] yourself Jesus
Christ dude
your wife's in pain and you still sat
there and watched it why didn't you
[__] uh
bring her back into the bedroom give her
a nice book and uh whatever peanut
butter and banana sandwich whatever the
Hell she's craving
um I don't know well I hope you had a
nice healthy baby boy or girl whatever
you had and um
I hope your wife hates you and not me
but uh for those who haven't seen my my
newest special yes we did we shot it in
uh with the latest cameras you can have
and we shot it in black and white I
always wanted to do a special in black
and white because
I just think it looks [__] cool as
[__] and uh and also I plan to do a
bunch of specials
and you know each one to have like its
own kind of unique look
you know so just imagine I got you know
some color ones and then boom I got this
black and white one and I shoot this
other one this way that way or whatever
um
I don't I don't know
I don't like HD the level of HDTV right
now it's so [__] clear it doesn't
look real it's like it looks like a
tropical fish tank half of these shows
you're sitting there watching a car
chase and you waste you're like waiting
for a clown fish to swim by the uh
past the screen I don't know I'm not in
it I'm not into it I'm an old man look
at me I'm releasing [__] vinyl
records and black and white specials I
am regressing
all right last week's 24 year old
version version
bill I wanted to weigh in on the 24 year
old virgin question with the female
perspective oh boy I love when the women
write in I always get it from the fellas
this one's from a lady she said this kid
is potentially sitting on a golden
ticket if he plays it right there are
girls that get really turned on by the
idea of [__] a virgin myself included
is that true
uh she said myself included when I was
still in the game it's sweet when you
don't know what you're doing
Tina I never would have known that
because as a guy you feel like there's
that pressure that you're supposed to
lead and you're supposed to know what
the [__] you're doing
from the get-go
um so anyways she goes on to say
and sweet will get you laid
oh it's sweet when you don't know what
you're doing and sweet will get you late
uh we'll knock your [__] brains out
because we take because we get to take
charge and we want to give you a great
time I've been with guys who think they
know what they are doing and it was far
worse than [__] a virgin a few words
of advice don't act all greasy and
pretend you know what's going on
what does greasy mean cool is this for
the Virgin yeah
just just saying [__] throw your
cards on the table
stand there with the [__] rock hard
dick going I don't know what to do with
it
what's happening
um anyways she said that's not a [__]
turn-on when you act all greasy and
pretend what you're doing and it will
reflect poorly on your abilities also
don't get too [__] wasted yeah a
little liquid courage isn't a bad thing
but too much booze in your system will
make you sloppy if you pick a decent
enough girl for your first [__] she
might tell her girlfriends but your
buddies will never know
um P.S bill got to see you in Ottawa and
you [__] killed it thanks and go [__]
yourself Jesus Christ
it's [__] right there that's the
[__] blunt force trauma truth of it
all
um I appreciate you being so goddamn
honest
you know
is that the way women talk when we're
not around
you guys sound like truckers too large
much all right adoption
and I'm not [__] on you either
because I know I sound like a trucker I
don't sound like a trucker all I do is
just add the southern accent because
everybody knows every truck is from down
south right speaking of down south
everybody
um I am going to be doing another
[__] tour of the South the Dirty
South and we're gonna get extra dirty
this time I'm telling you right now
I'm putting it together
all right we're not going to be doing
the main [__] ones that I've done in
the past Nashville Atlanta [__] that
all right [__] that all [__] day
all right we're going to Talladega we're
going to Mobile Alabama
we're gonna go into Mississippi
I wanna I wanna go into I wanna I'm
gonna I'm gonna I'm gonna I want to go
to like [__] some of these
off the beaten [__] path
Southern ones to uh do a bus tour
um I'm gonna I'm putting the [__]
team back together again just like The
Blues Brothers all right that's
something else in 2015 that's gonna
happen
we'll get in the [__] bus back we'll
get Steve the bus driver
all right furzie law head
and the coach and that's it
it's gonna happen again
um I'm actually right after I'm done
with this [__] podcast I'm calling my
agent I'm gonna pick a goddamn time
we're gonna we're gonna put it together
I love the [__] self
I love it all right adoption
server
just finished your new special amazing
as always thank you very much I very
much liked you a bit about adoption and
as someone who grew up in a family
oh as someone who grew up in a family
through adoption it's my honest opinion
that it's the best and most socially
responsible thing someone can do my
sister brother and myself were adopted
by folks my folks after my dad made the
choice back when he was a kid in the 70s
and met and adopted schoolmate who had
been through some [__] in Korea and
expressed his true gratitude for being
able to live a completely new life my
mom has made it clear that they could
have had their own and it wasn't a
question of possibility pain or timing
uh my dad just always felt the need to
do it I don't know where I'd be without
people like my parents in adoption
should really be how our new generation
in privileged countries like our own
acquire their children though I
understand acquiring children sounds
like the to-do list for an African
dictator either way thanks for the
thousands of last laughs I hope you and
Nia find tremendous joy in whatever you
decide to do any kid would be fortunate
for you guys to have
oh any kid would be fortunate have you
guys as a mom or a dad ah what a [__]
great guy
um
I gotta be honest with you dude with the
[__] world population problem the way
it is
you know what I mean
and then all the kids out there that uh
for whatever reason
you know I can't imagine over in uh
Iraq how many kids don't have [__]
moms or dads at this point
through that [__] [__] show over the
last 10 years anytime a war just just
[__] pulls everybody apart
um
and over here you know
well I don't know if they allow do they
allow
husbands and wives in the United States
military to both go over there
I wouldn't think so
they seem to not do that after that I
think after they had that one uh
that ship that went down to World War II
when there was like five brothers from
the same family were all on the same
ship
and the thing got torpedoed and some
poor parents lost all five of their kids
man [__] brutal I think the U.S
military does try to avoid that
so
um
no I I wouldn't have a problem with that
you should probably do it I'm [__] 46
right
then I talk about that in my Act
I need a headset I need to [__] get
like a 10 year old
so I'll still be alive when I graduates
College
um no I don't think there's anything
wrong with it I think it's a great thing
to do and also
you know not only is it great for the
kid it is great for I hate using the
word Society Mankind in general because
if you don't have any sort of Parental
Guidance and you're growing up in some
sort of foster home
you know it's just like you're just
gonna grow up you know with a bunch of
other [__] up kids and you just end up
doing what they're doing uh when the
person could actually
you know if you have parental guidance
you go to school you get a good job you
mean you know
you mean a nice lady or whatever you get
[__] married or what do you you chill
if you're all [__] angry from your
child and all that God knows what you go
out and go do right
um yes you know what you reconvinced me
all right underrated doing dishes at
spouse's family at spouse's family event
is underrated all right I was at my
sister-in-law's graduation party and
decided to help clean up by doing the
dishes I was able to skip out on boring
in-law conversations while picking up
some credit by offering to do the dishes
on top of it all I was able to catch the
Patriots Packers game on the kitchen TV
while everyone else was having was
having to make small talk dude that's
[__] genius
I hate small talk I can't stand going to
those [__] parties dude I'm gonna
steal that
whoever man or woman whoever wrote this
in hermaphrodite I don't know who the
[__] you are God bless you I got a nice
crowd uh I got a nice crowd going in the
kitchen and most of the men at the event
wanted to see the game we were rooting
for the Patriots to win so the Lions
would have the NFC North next time you
get a chance volunteer to do some easy
cleanup non-stop thanks and an easy out
from boring conversations wow man
I gotta tell you that might be the best
one in a while
that's that's goddamn genius
a musical mutt a dancing dog
um
so anyways what do you got here man look
at this 53 [__] minutes in 53 minutes
in and I'm out of [__] to talk about I'm
a little talked out people I apologize
you know pouring myself out
hype in this [__] special and uh
doing the radio
the radio goddamn tour let's you know
this is what I'm gonna do
I'm just going to select some right now
from my email account
where are we where are we here we go
click here
and then I click here I'm signing into
my account isn't this exciting I have no
idea what these questions are going to
be
uh
um
advice been out of the game it's changed
all right what do we see oh my God this
[__] email is long oh [__]
all right hey Billy badass I got a
situation here and I can't make heads of
tails of where I'm at with this girl a
modern day Casanova such as yourself
should be able to figure out how to read
this girl read this girl and it
advise me as the next as of the next
step to take
uh if there is one so here's my problem
your problem is [__] spelling and
punctuation so far my friend so here's
my problem I'm 24 years old and was in a
relationship with a girl for five years
from the ages of 14 to 19. when it ended
it was drawn out and she strung me along
until she was comfortable enough with
her next guy
to cut it off for good yeah that's what
you do when you're young
I wouldn't take it personal she's only
[__] 19 she doesn't know how to get
out of a relationship you know you guys
started dating at 14.
um anyways well she goes well I live in
a small town and the guy she went to was
a little [__] girl Gene wearing pissant
ah Wheezy easy easy
ah Jesus Christ dude I'm not I'm going
to read dude you sound like a [__]
bully I know right you know what you're
mad at him
all right I'm gonna give he Jesus Christ
dude
thank God I pulled up on that one I
would have to make an apology
um
they can't take an ass whooping without
calling the cops
Jesus Christ
I don't have a given advice let's just
read this to hear how [__] up this guy
is
by the way big reason why
I country
is our country the reason why I country
is going to hell in a hand basket is
because the guys like this I get because
they can't take an ass kicking without
calling the cops all right this guy's
old school uh nobody is getting their
ass beat anymore because of cop calling
ah Jesus
which assault is practically a prison
sentence right away I I digress dude
you're a [__] mouth breathing [__]
good Lord I'm actually ha I'm
happy that she's [__] away from you
see this is why we try to screen these
goddamn things
all right where are we where are we come
on somebody asked for if uh
Men's Room Studio Tour
Etc
all right let's see what this one is hi
Bill let's hope this one doesn't have uh
homophobic [__] all over it all right hi
Bill I heard your podcast yesterday I
was dying laughing when you talked about
the Men's Rooms and all the smelly
shenanigans that happen in there I'm a
woman who's never been in a men's public
restroom so that was a shockingly funny
Revelation my husband never tells me
it's disgusting in there perhaps he he's
used to it well I mean it's a public
restroom I by the way I've been in
plenty of ladies rooms
um I shouldn't say plenty I don't mean
to say it that way I've been in there
because I used to be a busboy at a
restaurant and in the morning I came in
and I had to clean up both bathrooms and
I was
not surprised at how filthy the men's
room was but the [__] ladies room
first of all this [__] toilet paper
all over the place I don't know what's
going on in there I think because they
have to sit down to pee they just build
a nest I have no idea and I'll spare you
the [__] details all right but it
looks like you know
just imagine a ticker tape parade
combined with bodily fluids
I'm sorry but that's what it looked like
he goes on the other hand the woman's
restrooms are quite the opposite God
forbid you make a sound in there it's
like an unspoken rule that women can't
fart loudly in stalls if you ask me this
is so unfair that we ladies have to hold
it in well you guys are doing it to
yourself that's the ladies room please
don't blame the guys for that one
well you know in society it's not
acceptable for us to fart in public if a
guy does it it's funny ow [__] grow a
dick
stop playing the goddamn victim all
right let one rip and have your dress
fly up like Marilyn Monroe I don't give
a [__] anyways I had the privilege
privilege to use the woman's restroom in
South in a South Korea airport and each
stall had a device that lets you play
classical music or nature sounds to
match the posterior trumpet blasting
that's about to shoot out of my dainty
butt
it was the best bathroom trip of my life
anywho I don't know if you got my email
months before my offer still stands
you're welcome oh to stop by our
Animation Studio Jesus Christ I was
getting nervous there
um
oh all right all right okay cool all
right
where do we go here where do we go um
do I dare to read I'm sorry you feel
that way feedback I got one more minute
to do here
loved every minute of it man like the
black and white absolutely awesome
special keep them coming please oh
that's awesome that's awesome I can't
even tell you guys how psyched I am that
you guys like this this special
um
and for those who are wondering why we
shot the way we do is because I love
stand-up comedy and I just feel like it
should be shot
like a movie you know what I mean
like stand-up comedy has this weird sort
of thing where it has this a ton of
respect for people like dude I don't
know how you get up there I could never
do that blah blah blah yet it's also
looked at like you're the guy with the
lampshade on your head
and I'll never forget when I did a half
hour for Comedy Central I know I've told
this story before and they did the
promos for it and they basically shot
you sitting on a stool sort of making
weird faces that the camera at least is
what they were asking you to do asking
you to do and uh they just played this
trumpet
like the promo it's like you know Bill
Burr's half hour special and they just
had me sitting there like shrugging my
shoulders like hey this is my half hour
special and this trumpet
was playing in the background
[Music]
I swear to God I remember I watched it
on I was sitting at home
this is my first half hour special I was
all excited and that [__] muted
trumpet came it sounded like it was
heckling me
like that's the soundtrack to what the
[__] I just did
you know what I just I just
I don't know I don't [__] know but
that's the greatest thing about this age
of specials is that comedians have so
much control that you can actually uh
shoot the [__] thing the way you want
to
um
which we did
and
um that is all that is the podcast for
this week everybody I I know I only did
an hour this week I uh I just let's let
me get through this next [__] acting
gig and then uh I'll be back flapping my
[__] gums again next week uh come
back a little stronger all right that's
it go [__] yourselves I'll talk to you
next week oh I didn't even bring it up
the Patriots beat the [__] charges
um looked to be a great game I was
actually punching up this [__] script
so I've yet to watch the game and um I
did see that play that you know we
intercepted it and brought it back and
there was that great hit
and you know those guys they gotta just
because someone gets [__] laid out
now doesn't mean it's like helmet to
helmet that was like a great hit
um but I actually I do like you know as
much as everybody's saying that the NFL
oh it's you know they're turning into
this [__] League I like that there
isn't helmet to helmet hits
I like that they're trying to get that
out of the game because I got to be
honest with you you know if you're
younger I can see why you don't like it
because you haven't seen any of the guys
that you liked when you were a kid be 50
60 years old and
you know dealing with the effects of it
like you know the latest one of the
latest ones that shocked me was Tony
Dorsett the great Tony Dorsett watching
him struggle with like
you know anger issues and all that type
of thing due to the
the hits he took in his career uh I like
that they're having him lead with the
shoulder and even then I mean you still
your head can snap back it's it's always
going to be a violent game but I think
it's great
um that they are getting it out of there
because it's still a [__] awesome
game I don't think that guys have to be
like
suffering the way these players are
suffering for to still be a great game
so I don't have a problem with it having
said all that that was a [__] call
that was a [__]
hell of a play and a touchdown and uh
I was nervous about that game because I
respect the Chargers and [__] Philip
Rivers
um
so anyways I don't know what to tell you
uh Patriots attended three tied with the
Broncos thank God we beat them so
we are uh you know provided we went we
win the rest of the way out or the
Broncos lose one we will have home
field advantage once again and uh we're
looking good but I don't know man
I still think the Broncos would be tough
to beat them twice it'd be tough to beat
the Colts twice
be tough to beat the Chargers twice it
just is I don't by any means think that
it would be you know all these Pats fans
like no we're going to the ball dude I
don't by any means think it would be a
cakewalk but uh or obviously a home
field advantage will be a huge thing so
I just figured I'd end the podcast by
saying a bunch of obvious [__] I hope
you enjoyed this week's podcast thanks
once again to everybody who's watching
my special and if you haven't watched it
yet if you could carve out some time to
watch it it really helps me because uh
you know Netflix is a ratings thing just
like any other network so if you've
already seen it thank you so much please
tell your friends if you haven't seen me
yet uh and you get a chance I know
you're busy I really appreciate you be
helping me out
foreign
what's up everybody and welcome back to
the anything better podcast NFL Edition
for uh going into wow man week number
14. it's flying by
um and uh yeah man look I'm happy I had
good week last week I don't know Bill I
don't know how Bill did we didn't talk
about it but I know that I went three I
said I got killed
did you
don't you remember my text messages I
thought you oh I know you won I know you
won the one game how did you do I said I
got killed oh well I went one and three
again oh okay well I went three and one
I'm finally [__] finally over this
this hump but only by a game and a half
so we got to keep our guard up yeah but
Paul you were in such a [__] hole I
was down eight
you were down eight games and you've
come storming back
um hey that's what happens when you lay
off the Packers okay
the Packers you were like stubborn with
those guys man I thought he was gonna
turn it around but uh so Andrew what is
that that
um I was 23 24-1 what am I now I'm 25 uh
20 26 uh 25 and one
all right and Bill's uh 23 and 25 and 4.
so he's 500.
no way I'm 500.
wait one in three the past two weeks man
I'm like [__] two and six dude no 22
26 and four so that's that's that's oh
22 oh so he's down two gate 24 and dude
who ties four times I've never seen
anything like well that's not me that's
the bookie
games where they picked a perfect number
I mean in Vegas I would have lost
well Bill I know you're a little more
forgiving here I noticed a little Trend
here some teams have have what do they
call it stabilized to fix the tides to
turn the whatever it is you know you
know I always I'm bad
right in the ship turn change the rudder
Bill's bad with names and I'm bad with
sayings some of these teams have righted
the ship and uh wait this is actually
week number 14 so bill has first pick
this week
bill has you say some of these teams
righted the ship I mean this is the last
three weeks all of a sudden the lines
are good I'm supposed to believe that
they're gonna be good for the rest of
the year they're favored by one and I'm
supposed to believe that Vikings just
stink
that's what you know it's dude uh the
Raiders have won three in a row the
lions are starting to win but I'm not
going to say the Lions I know what does
that mean though yeah I mean look
the Lions never rated a [__] the Lion's
ship is in the same direction I love the
Raiders tonight but then I'm just like
those [__] [__] are gonna go back
to who they were
yeah they're playing a bad Rams team
though I don't know
um well you have the pick of the litter
how can the Rams be that bad Paul
dude how could it be that bad they just
won the [__] Super Bowl how could
they be that bad you wanna get away from
that game I don't like it I'm gonna tell
you why because Cooper cup catches 11
passes a game and he's out and he did
that last year when they won too without
that guy dude it's a it's just a
different team you're telling me
in 2022 if you lose one white wide
receiver you go from winning the Super
Bowl to being [__] three and eight on
whatever the [__] they are I'm supposed
to believe that
11 12 passes a game for like 130 yards
and he's like uncut he's an animal I'm
not saying he's not but I'm just saying
I mean that is throwing it to him all
last year that is funny if you pointed
him out in a bar and you're like you see
that dude yeah that guy's the reason the
Rams are bad they'd be like get the [__]
out of here
I know he's like my height
you're playing darts he's playing darts
with a beer in his hand you like that
guy
um
yep it's an even number I got first pick
this week I'm not gonna lie to you I am
I am flailing
dude you're down I don't know who
anybody is I don't know who's shot I
don't know who's not
um I'm gonna go back to something I
liked earlier this year
which is Joe burrow and the Cincinnati
Bengals I know it's a uh it's a rivalry
and whatever but Joe mixon's coming back
he's off the concussion protocol to Sean
Watson still shaking off the cobwebs for
being in that jerk off shop I'm gonna
take the [__] Bengals laying five and
a half Paul I don't like five I would
have loved four and a half I'm not gonna
lie that was a pick I was gonna take
it's a great pick it's a w
all right why do you chase me like that
all right why do you tricks me like that
why do you call me up in the first chord
and say your bet looks great I never do
[__] like that to you it was it wasn't
the first quarter I didn't think it's
the end of the game
you guys gave Aaron judge all that money
I I didn't call you up and say what the
[__] are you doing
I'll be honest with you dude I don't
know if I like that
dude 360 million for a guy that's been
hurt a lot it's a lot hey I'm glad he's
here but it's gonna be like one of those
you guys can afford it the Knicks the
Knicks with Alan Houston that that hurt
him the Yankees can afford to pay some
giant
[__] six years if he's on the bench
with a swollen ankle
all right I'm gonna I'm gonna pick one
we lost the end of Bogarts it's a free
agency yet another guy we got nothing
for where'd he go
San Diego they're [__] stacked oh
dude San Diego is putting all the chips
super Padres
um Sam get out there and uh you know
they're not gonna [__] pay you leave
dude I got [__] water coming up on
the floor here it's like have they
figured out [__] they can't figure out
how to make the [__] basement not get
what I got water coming up from the
tiles where I'm sitting right now I got
water in in this room right now I got
water it's a sign pick the Dolphins
[Laughter]
ship and all of a sudden he's out on the
Open Seas
I'm gonna tell you something dude
I'm gonna take the Pittsburgh Steelers
minus two at home against the Lamar
Jackson list Ravens I know it's a div I
know it's a kind of a rivalry but
I think this kid Kenny Pickett this
quarterback of the Steelers has got two
back-to-back good games they're home
it's only two points and no Lamar
Jackson if that doesn't look who am I if
that doesn't do it I don't know what
does it so I'm gonna take that game well
the rabbit's got that kid from Utah that
the uh their coach is saying it would be
a starting quarterback somewhere else
Paul
the youths the two Utes the toyotes the
two Utes that beat [__] USC and a lot
of Ohio State to back in ass first into
the [__] playoffs Bill who is that
actor Bill who is that actor who said
did you say you he played Thurman not
Urban
okay he was great that guy
uh he's an incredible actor
um
all right I like uh Sneaky Pete Carroll
uh you love Seattle Seahawks minus four
against the Panthers I don't know why
they're only minus four I looked up to
see if there was any injuries or
something
why are they only minus four they just
got where the [__] uh
Baker Mayfield
I mean Paul they're a team in flocks
you know what you don't want me to jinx
you so I'm not going to say
no I've said I'm gonna be a friend I'm
not gonna use me all you want it doesn't
[__] matter I'm just I'm I'm just
joking I I actually like I actually love
both of your picks all right
I'm trying to find my charger here Burr
loves to see Bill loves the Seahawks
like I I go with the Colts or Packers
not true I've laid off them for a few
weeks but I do love a great coach
you know no matter I mean Pete Carol
figures out a way to get it done all
right I'm gonna leave it at that I'm
gonna be a gentleman
he figures out a way to get it done
he's got a [__] crowd noise whatever
the [__] he's got to do
I like Gino Smith
you know
we have the [__] that quarterback is
this is a weird one
dude why are the Vikings and lions a one
and a half line that's just weird to me
dude the Vikings are like one of the
best teams in football until like a week
ago and they had a couple of bad weeks
and the Lions have a couple of good
weeks that's what I'm saying all of a
sudden I'm supposed to believe
that the lines of the new lines and the
Vikings are now what
there's something going on I tried to
look up uh
injuries or something on that one
all right I'm gonna do all capali oh
Paulie's gonna throw a curveball here
I'm gonna take
you ready for this
I'm gonna take the New York Jets getting
10 in Buffalo
thank you
thank you why I think the Jets have been
picked because the Jets pick off the
Jets picked off the bills more than
anybody this year uh or or Josh Allen in
general and that's that's too high
that's a heavy line for a good defense
yeah I think it's a heavy line for a
good defense and it is a rivalry it's 10
points I mean the Jets could also get
blown out
but I just like the points with a I like
the points with their defense and this
quarterback that's better than the kid
they drafted so I'm going to take the 10
points with the Jets
yeah I gotta be honest with you Paul I
don't think I haven't been too impressed
with the Ravens defense oh sorry the
bills defense
whoever the [__] they added that free
agent to that defense that [__]
lunatic linebacker I was like oh my God
the bills are gonna they're gonna walk
and he's out for the year he just tore
his ACL he's out for the year Von
Miller's gone
oh God I hate to hear that yeah but you
know in Seattle laying 10 you'd love to
hear it well I hope we I hope he
recovers soon
um I'm gonna take the let's see here I
don't know why
but uh I'm gonna take the New York
football Giants plus seven and a half
first the [__] Eagles I just [__]
uh you know division rivalry Giants
always play good defense Eagles had a
nice fun time last week against the
Titans they're feeling pretty good going
into Christmas I think they have a
couple too many gingerbread cookies and
uh you know
they let up a late one an old freckles
gets a win there you know what dude I
didn't know if I was gonna take that and
I was thinking about it I'm glad you did
but you just pushed me to do something
why not I'm gonna take the Vegas Raiders
tonight [__] it six and a half points I
think they win they're on a little you
know what I was arrested I was hoping
you're gonna take the Vikings and tell
everybody that calm down in the Norris
you know what I think the Raiders three
games in a row they seem like they're
clicking
the Rams are you talking about a frail
flailing the Rams are
the Rams might even be going for a draft
pick at this point dude they're three in
whatever no Cooper cup
prime time for the Raiders hey when I
was in fifth grade the first team I ever
played for I was a Raider number 27. I'm
gonna go in with the Raiders tonight how
about that I like it all right Paul's
kind of laying off this one and now I'm
coming back around to it I like the
Ravens
I don't give a [__] that the Steelers
had two good games in a row this is
still the Ben Roethlisberger hangover I
know Lamar Jackson isn't there but I
like this kid out of Utah just like this
picture
you know
sorry
I actually read two paragraphs on it oh
Paul this movie's done done on Tuesday
that's my Super Bowl
amazing shows this weekend three more
next weekend and then I'm just gonna
[__] drown myself in Bourbon
yeah I'm coming off the wagon Paul are
you hard
nice I'm talking like [__] who's that
guy who drank himself to I didn't drink
himself death he killed himself
I heard you could just or you could just
pour yourself a drink
or you could just pour yourself a drink
sit back oh look who finally turned his
life around [__] three weeks ago and
he's acting like the guy that didn't
stay up till four in the morning six in
the morning on the tour bus
I know I know
bro dude come home come home before the
street lights come on tomorrow night you
mean
dude is it sad that it took me over 40
years to learn how to eat and drink like
a [__] normal person
what about me I I went 50 years because
I couldn't do it I finally had to
[__] quit
um I like all of them oh I like all of
our picks
um that's it right is that those are my
those are the picks where I have one
more
you have one more it's kind of stupid
for us to go head-to-head if we're
trying to beat the book because that's
definitely a plus what's up the Ravens
and uh oh okay that's right no I took
the Steelers the Jets the Raiders and I
got one more my last my fourth and final
pick for week 14 well you know what bill
made it easy taking the Giants off the
board so that I don't have to worry
about betting with my heart over there
all right this is a tricky one guys oh
this is a tricky one we'll probably let
the Dolphins sit there against the
Chargers the Chargers Paul here's why
you suck you want to know why hey what
did you when did you become the [__]
guy helping the other guy out well I
need the help I said Dolphins three
times I said no he keeps pushing the
Dolphins here's why I don't like the
here's why I don't like it dude the
Chargers are now six and six and they're
coming off a loss in their home and they
can't they can't they need the game
um
hey Paul everybody needs a game this
time of year huh
you know what dude how about this oh
this is nuts I'm taking
oh he's got the finger going
I saw something in the Tampa Bay
Buccaneers I saw something
at the end of that game when he came
back he something happened with him and
Evans and I think I I liked how the
defense played kept him in the game
they're getting three and a half points
no Garoppolo everybody's high on this
new kid who's coming in for Garoppolo
going oh this Purdy kid he came in he
played great [__] that Tampa Bay is
gonna [__] run after this kid and
Blitz him and I like him getting more
than three points so I'm gonna take the
Tampa Bay Bucks on the road road dogs
three and a half against the favored
Niners there you go
laughs
like are you expecting a big reaction
from the two of us that was silence and
then he filled it up going there you go
I put that there you go you guys are
like all right we're gonna [__] in
getting the points
there you go
dude you still fighting are you still
fighting that cough dude
only when I laughed like [__] do
whatever I have
it's not covet it's not Ebola
it's not the flu
I don't know what it is I've gotten
tested for [__] everything
I'm just happy it's not it's not
shingles
all right Bill well now we have one last
thing to do uh let them [__] Monday
night special
we [__] fun this year all right well
it is your New England Patriots at
Arizona Cardinals and the Patriots are
minus one and a half
where I don't know just why are we
favorites we have no [__] offense
whatsoever our defense is good
we have no offense
I like don't make me do this Jones going
Mac Jones going past the [__] ball
the running game sucks I was like I like
that I like that oh you know I like that
and you know what he wasn't that play
call was he wasn't lying dude I liked it
Matt Patricia uh it's been getting a lot
of criticism just in general for his
choices we'll say as far back as the
Lions go when he was with Detroit people
weren't happy with him there they
thought it was a mistake nothing that
happens in Detroit counts it's a
family-owned [__] team everybody
goes out there and fails who's the last
person that went out there and [__]
did well
hey Bill as far back as I could remember
we always passed the ball
Good Fellas nothing all right there you
go uh and there it is what is it there
you go I just got a clip I have to watch
on this [__] goddamn thing it's never
gonna end uh this movie's never gonna
end all right let's go well the
underover's 43 and a half uh the line is
one and a half
I mean if I take my heart out but I say
Arizona in the under
wait is Kyler Murray playing what the
[__] going on with the Cardinals
Kyler Murray is playing
Carla Murray's playing he's a pain in
the ass they stink
Andrew what's that record so bad that
they're they're
one and a half Point dogs at home
against an anemic offense
Paul help me out with this one you're
seeing it Paul you you've gone six and
two I've gone two and six this is a tale
of two two gamblers here
cards are cards are four and eight Pats
are six and six but yeah dude the
Cardinals just the Cardinals don't have
it dude Belichick's gonna win the game
that kid number nine you guys got's
unreal he's unreal dude that kid
um
yeah I like the fire and Mac Jones
saying like what the [__] are we doing
let's go all right we'll take the Pats
with the points we'll say they'll let
Matt throw it Mac was good with Matt
Mac's gonna throw one
all right what else does Ben FGM let us
do at this point to try to win a [__]
Monday night special
uh you can't pick a starting quarterback
to throw a touchdown
wait so no we got it you got Mac Jones
throwing one Patriots to win by two and
what do you think under over the under
over has been a lot of our our Achilles
heel
it's 43 and a half
Bill Belichick doesn't win shootouts so
if he's gonna win he's gonna [__]
hold him and we really don't score any
[__] points I'd say the under that's
what makes sense all right up a few what
you might tease it to like 47 or
something if you want to be safe can we
how do you tease it uh it'll change the
odds a little bit but you just
you'd be making the bet at a different
uh line uh you're selling me a car right
now that's what you're doing you're
gonna give me four grand for this hunk
of [__] absolutely I'm just gonna add
four grand to the [__] price tag no
you know what his gut was that I like
his wreath I like your reasoning I like
your reasoning Belichick if Bella checks
in a fight they're not gonna put up a
lot of points I like that let's go under
Mac Jones to throw one and and the
Patriots to win the game by two
all right I'm going I'm Ryan versus I'm
on the rosie train right now
what'd you say when you when you you
finished your big thing
I go what did you say there you go
hey there you go that's right or
something I don't know there you go
because you guys were just silent I gave
this good reasoning and you guys just
stared at me I go there you go
no you gave like a halftime speech we
should have been running out of the
[__] lot from ready to play with just
Saturday like there you go
um all right everybody well this has
been anything better NFL Edition preview
for week number 14. those are our picks
that's our Monday night special Mac
Jones to throw one
um Patriots to win minus one and a half
and under 43 and a half uh how do you
get the BET MGM app and then and there
you go
and there you go yeah and there you go
um download the betmgm app use bonus
code burr b-u-r-r Put as little as ten
dollars in and uh bet up to a thousand
dollars risk free all you gotta do
download the app use bonus code Burr
b-u-r-r as little as 10 bucks guys and
they'll match it up to a thousand bucks
even if you lose you're gonna you're
gonna get it so I don't know what you're
waiting on and uh there you go they said
a half brakes just half Sicilian
couldn't be 500 against Ben MGM in
December
hey they said that until they met you
and let me tell you something kid I
didn't believe you I didn't believe in
you in September I didn't believe in you
in October but now
I believe in you more than any other
degenerate Gambler I know
if the kid was eight games back in week
ten eight games back in week 10 and I'm
over the book let's get them again Bill
let's get him again
I'm just trying to keep my [__] nose
above the [__] water here I'm rooting
for Bill I don't care about the the
Jimmy the Greek this year I'm rooting
for me and Bill to look at that MGM and
go two years in a row once they started
[__] us on the Monday night special
then it became us against them that's
what happened we United as a team
um all right but I'm not pulling my
weight so if you [__] cut me I
understand all right um all right man go
Raiders tonight enjoy the game tonight
everybody enjoy uh well they're not
gonna see this until whatever whatever
Saturday enjoy your football Sunday
we'll be back for week 15. we hope you
enjoyed the last anything better regular
podcast we'll be back with that in a
week so
um there you go enjoy take care
the rate is all right we'll see all
right thanks guys yep all right bye-bye
bye
and remember guys Tibet you got to be 21
years of age or older to wager in
Arizona Colorado DC Iowa Indiana Kansas
Michigan Mississippi New Jersey New York
Nevada Pennsylvania Tennessee
uh Virginia West Virginia or Wyoming
only new customer offer paid in free
bets visit betmgm.com for terms and
conditions uh excludes Michigan
disassociated persons uh please gamble
responsibly gambling problem call 1-800
next step for Arizona call
1-800-522-4704 Colorado DC Nevada
Wyoming West Virginia
1-800-270-7117 for confidential help
Michigan
1-800 Gambler in Indiana New Jersey
Pennsylvania and West Virginia
1-800 bets off in Iowa call or text the
Tennessee Red Line
800-889-9789 in Tennessee or call
1-88-77-9696 for Mississippi sports
betting is void in Georgia Hawaii Ohio
and Utah and other states were
prohibited
promotional offers not available in
Nevada
[Applause]
[Music]